[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre cet
après-midi les travaux de la haute
assemblée avec une audition de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus les
sénateurs s'intéresse cette après midi à
la situation dans les ehpad des
établissements qui héberge nos aînés et
qui ont été lourdement frappé par cette
épidémie avec plus de 10000 personnes
décédées je vous laisse écouter cette
audition concentrent des personnes
vulnérables d'après le dernier point
épidémiologique de santé publique france
publié la semaine dernière 14 mille
quatre cent cinquante cinq personnes
décédées sur un le total des trente
mille cinq cent quarante quatre décès
imputables aux qu'ovide soit 47 %
étaient des résidents d pad décédé à
l'hôpital ou plus souvent dans
l'établissement certains ehpad
présentent des bilans effarant nos
auditions territoriales ont mis au jour
certaines difficultés comme le manque
d'équipements de protection des salariés
des résidents mais aussi des visiteurs
des difficultés de gestion des
personnels une insuffisante présence
médicale des carences de remontée
d'informations ou d'équipements
informatiques
la double tutelle des départements des
ars a souvent été pointée comme une
difficulté se traduirait par une absence
de tutelle ou une insuffisance de
contrôle
quelles sont les questions que nous
souhaitera vous posez la crise sanitaire
est intervenu sur un terrain très
fragilisée elle a servi de révélateur à
de nombreuses difficultés que nous
connaissions auparavant qu'elle a été
précisément l'ampleur de ses difficultés
qu'elle a été leur impact sur les
personnes âgées
le seul critère de l'âge ou de la
résidence en ehpad at il été objecté à
des admissions à l'hôpital dans
l'affirmative quand ou pour combien de
personnes il faudra être précis dans les
réponses faites par que vous serez amené
à faire notre audi sur le cet après midi
a notamment pour objectif de répondre à
ces questions je demanderai nos
intervenants de présenter brièvement
leur principal message en 5 minutes
maximum cinq minutes
j'ai le compteur afin de laisser le
maximum de temps bien sûr aux échanges
et je vais demander à chacun des
intervenants commissaire inclus d'être
concis dans les questions les réponses
et d'indiquer précisément pour la
commissaire à qui la question s'adresse
maintenant conformément à la procédure
applicable aux commissions d enquête
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
je rappelle auparavant que tout
témoignage mensonger devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire est
puni de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 euros d'amande
alors monsieur jean-claude bredin que
prêtez-vous serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et dit je le jure je madame
florence arnaiz maumé prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dire je le jure
madame virginie lasserre prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
juge le jour monsieur pascal mais verte
prenez prêté serment également de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité de
lever la main droite et de dire je le
sais jean pierre rizo prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité avec la vérité levé
la main droite et je le jure je le jure
monsieur pascal champvert prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité ne levez la main droite
edit je le veux je le jure très bien
donc nous allons faire un bref tour de
table et nous passerons si tout question
de chacun des trois rapporteurs puis aux
questions regroupées de nos commissaires
je vous rappelle également que le port
du masque est obligatoire même en
parlant avec les difficultés que ça peut
engendrer donc je vous remercie pour
votre vigilance
voilà elle rappelait également que
d'après le même bulletin épidémiologique
que j'ai déjà cité la plupart des
clusters professionnels sont localisés
dans le secteur public une grande
prudence
n'est ce pas roger voilà alors merci
et je sais de la parole à monsieur est
donc madame marnaise oui laurent solly
si oui vous mettez bonjour merci
beaucoup merci à tous les membres de la
commission denquête donc jean-claude
breloques et moi même avant le plaisir
et l'honneur de représenter le synerpa
le synerpa c'est le premier syndicat
national des ehpad privé également
services à domicile privé à l'attention
des personnes fragiles et résidences
services seniors nous représentons 2700
adhérents sur l'ensemble de la france
1900 ehpad 600 services à domicile et
150 résidences services seniors soit
plus de 250000 personnes hébergées et
des pour 135 mille salariés en activité
alors la crise effectivement nous
l'avons travers traversée de façon
extrêmement dure et difficile nous avons
à ce stade trois grandes périodes dont
nous voudrions évidemment parler d'abord
la période janvier février qui est la
période d'une prise de conscience longue
et difficile où le secteur a été
finalement assez peu pris en compte dans
l'organisation de la crise qu vide
nous avons au niveau du synerpa
peut-être été informé un petit peu avant
les autres puisque nous avons la
particularité d'avoir des adhérents qui
sont présents en chine et en italie
notamment le groupe orpea présent à mes
côtés donc nous avons eu dès fin janvier
début février
des annonces assez difficile à croire
même de la part de la chine et des
adhérents que nous avions là bas ce qui
a fait que nous avons peut-être
prêterait préparer un tout petit peu
plus en amont et une peut-être présenter
une inquiétude
un petit peu plus soutenu dès le début
février puisque nous écrivons dès le
début février à madame duzan alors
ministre de la santé pour avoir
des informations demandées à être réunis
demandé à avoir des protocoles pour la
crise qui s'annonce si elle s'annonce
puisque à ce moment là nous n'avons
aucun cas dans nos établissements nous
n'avons aucune réponse tout au long du
mois de février
je me permets de rappeler le cabinet
ministériel autour du 15 février
madame busin quittant ses fonctions il
était compliqué d'avoir des informations
à ce moment là à cette date du 20
février nous n'avons qu'un guide d'une
centaine de pages qui organise
l'intégralité de la prise en charge
sanitaire le mot et pas de doit
apparaître trois ou quatre fois dans ce
guide 200 pages et aucun protocole ne
nous est dédié dès le 22 février la
lombardie est confiné nous nous rendons
compte que le virus arrive puisque déjà
des alertes sont palpables au tour de
creil et puis enfin en outre france
notamment dans l'oise et donc nous au
niveau du synerpa décrétons d'envoyer à
nos adhérents le 24 février
des premières informations leur
demandant de mettre en place des gestes
barrières d affichage du gel
hydroalcoolique des masques comme c'est
possible prendre la température et
éventuellement de noter les gens qui
entrent et qui sortent donc nous
demandons à nos adhérents de le faire
dès la semaine du 24 février
alors même que nous n'avons reçu aucun
protocole puis l'ensemble des
fédérations se plaignent auprès
d'olivier ferrand de n'avoir aucun
protocole et il nous réunit enfin le 3
mars il y a un avant et un après 3 mars
puisque à partir du 3 mars le ministère
de la santé et la dgcs à mes côtés
également prennent la mesure vraiment de
l'attak qui devient de plus en plus
violentes dans les établissements et la
15 jours d'enfer arrive à partir du 3
mars 5 mars nos adhérents notamment de
grands tests et de bourgogne franche
comté nous alerte sur des situations
extrêmement compliquée où énormément de
résidences sont touchées
attaquée de façon très violente avec des
symptômes inconnu que nous maîtrisions
pas qu'ils sont très très divers variés
des variabilités dans la prise en compte
de la maladie et dans les symptômes qui
laisse tout le monde
atterré et les ennuis commencent puisque
effectivement à partir de cette période
comme vous l'avez dit nous avons eu de
cesse d'avoir des difficultés de prod
approvisionnements ne pays de masclat
sp2 chirurgicaux 2 / blues puis ensuite
des problématiques de transfert puis
ensuite des problématiques de mesures
barrières de confinement en chambre
qu'il a fallu mettre en place tout au
long du mois de mars puis ensuite des
problèmes de test et toutes ces périodes
que nous pourrons détaillé pendant
l'audition ont été des parcours du
combattant
nous avons quand même main dans la main
avec l'état et les fédérations pu
réaliser l'intégralité des protocoles
alors toujours toujours au début avec
deux ou trois semaines de retard ce sera
notre notre drame mais mais enfin nous
avons réussi à tous les mettre en place
au fil du temps ce qui fait que à la
sortie de la crise effectivement courant
avril quand la situation et surtout fin
avril quand la situation s'apaise sur
les 7000 ehpad
on a environ 60% d'établissements qui
ont passé la crise plutôt facilement
sans être touché 30 à 35% qui sont
touchés et 3 à 5% d'établissement très
très durement touché un établissement
très durement touchée peut avoir eu la
moitié de ses résidents de ces
personnels attaqué peut avoir eu jusqu'à
20 30 40 décès dans son établissement
donc voilà cette crise finalement ça
pèse
à partir de fin avril début mai grâce à
une politique de test enfin soutenu à
partir du 10 avril
et puis nous sommes rentrés à partir de
mi mai dans une troisième période qui
est toujours actuelle qui est la période
est bien de déconfinement d'abord et
puis aujourd'hui de surveillance accrue
avec parfois quelques confinement mais
avec une maladie qui n'offrent plus du
tout les mêmes symptômes et les mêmes
drames qu'au mois d'avril
donc nous sommes encore aujourd'hui
évidemment dans l'expectative merci
madame
là c'est le seul président de la
commission d'enquêté spéciale mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs par péter
mois peut-être de me présenter
rapidement donc jennifer directrice
générale la cohésion sociale c'est une
direction qui pilote je pense important
de le rappeler aujourd'hui à un niveau
interministériel des politiques qui
prennent en charge les populations qui
sont les plus vulnérables les personnes
âgées les personnes handicapées les plus
précaires les enfants relevant de la
protection de l'enfance les majeurs
protégés ainsi que les femmes victimes
de violence et elle gère par ailleurs
les politiques d'accueil des jeunes
enfants
je souhaiterais souligner en propos
liminaire le dévouement aussi et
l'implication des professionnels du
médico social tout au long de cette
crise et m'associer à la peine des
familles dont les proches sont décédés
qui souvent n'ont pas pu vivre leur
deuil de façon normale en propos
liminaire aussi rapidement
je souhaite rappeler plusieurs choses
d'abord indiqué que l'épidémie que nous
avons connue était une épidémie avec un
virus que nous ne connaissions pas que
nous avons appris à connaître au fur et
à mesure et il est de ce fait difficile
de juger ex post ce qui aurait dû être
fait sans prendre en compte me
semble-t-il cette dimension deuxième
sujet peut-être rappeler que cadres et
la responsabilité de l'état et complexe
pour cette épidémie
parce que toute la difficulté de l'état
a été à la fois de prendre soin du plus
grand nombre dans la logique de
l'intérêt général tout en prenant en
compte aussi la dimension évidemment
individuelle et puis quelques mots
également pour dire que l'état me
semble-t-il doit pouvoir aussi
lucidement des centres et son point de
vue cette crise a évidemment montré que
les collectivités locales ont été
pourvoyeuse de solution dans la crise et
qu'il faut sans doute s'appuyer sur cela
pour gérer l'épidémie dans la durée mon
intervention sera brève et portera sur
essentiellement deux points rappelé le
rôle de la dgcs dans la gestion des
crises et indiqué qu'elle a été la
gestion de la crise dans les ehpad et
les enseignements à en tirer
premier point de mon propos quel rôle
les positionnements de la direction
générale
la cohésion sociale dans la gestion de
la crise épidémique je le disais en
propos liminaire la dgcs gère
principalement les populations les plus
vulnérables qui est de ce fait ont été
les plus touchés par l'épidémie
notamment les personnes âgées avec des
lignes de conduite que j'avais donnée à
l'ensemble des équipes qui se résumer en
trois choses être réactif pragmatique et
la proximité avec le terrain avec des
missions et un fonctionnement de la dgcs
que j'ai souhaité pouvoir activer et
mobilisé au plus tôt de la crise sachant
que nous participions évidemment aux
réunions du centre de crise sanitaire
mais que néanmoins j'ai sauté activé une
cellule de crise spécifique à la dgcs
pour avoir une approche vraiment je
dirais métier dès le 27 février avec
deux objectifs principaux qui me semble
important de rappeler aujourd'hui
élaborer des consignes spécifiques à
l'intention des acteurs du champ social
et médico-social à cette fin dès le 14
janvier
des messages de mise en alerte de
l'ensemble des secteurs avaient été
envoyés et le 6 mars par exemple pour a
détaillé les choses nous demandions le
déclenchement des plans bleus sur
l'ensemble du territoire
deuxième objectif de cette mobilisation
du fonctionnement de la dgcs et être en
lien constant avec l'ensemble des
professionnels intervenant sur nos
secteurs pour ne pas être décalée avec
le terrain et ça me semblait absolument
indispensable et à cette fin et parce
qu'elles sont vraies et florence arnaiz
maumé en témoigneront j'ai mis en place
des audioconférences extrêmement
régulière avec l'ensemble des acteurs de
terrain donc les fédérations les
associations pour pouvoir finalement
discuter en temps réel de l'évolution
dépit des missions de territoire et
pouvoir échanger sur les consignes de
façon à ce qu'elle ne soit pas
évidemment décalé avec les réalités du
terrain deuxième point de mon propos
comment était géré cette crise dans le
vé pa des quelques enseignements en
tirer je souhaite rappeler évidemment on
a tous ces chiffres en tête vous les
avez redonné monsieur le président cette
crise a été d'une ampleur inédite avec
plus de 30000 morand en france dont à
peu près la moitié de la moitié de
résidents en ehpad
il faut rappeler également que cette
crise a été très disparate selon les
territoires puisqu'on a en île de france
par exemple 92% des ehpad qui ont été
touchés contre 37% en nouvelles
aquitaine quels enseignements tirer de
cette crise on n'est pas premier
enseignement peut-être protéger les
résidents des ehpad notamment par un
confinement strict en ehpad est-ce que
cela a été une erreur
je pense qu'il faut il faut s'interroger
et et discuter de cela
ce que je voudrais redire par rapport à
ce sujet c'est que l'état a demandé mais
au vu des connaissances et des moyens
disponibles le 11 mars que les ehpad
suspendre les visites des familles ce
qui était par ailleurs demandé par une
grande majorité des fédérations dans un
intérêt cela était demandé par l'état
dans un intérêt pour défendre un intérêt
collectif ne pas faire entrer le virus
dans les ehpad qui en tant que lieu de
vie communautaire est un espace à risque
même avec les moyens de prévention
si l'intérêt individuel d'une personne
âgée pouvait être de voir ses proches
plus souvent cela représentait un risque
de faire entrer de virus et de
contaminer non seulement de résident
mais surtout les autres résidents et
puis dans le protocole diffusé le 20
avril s'appuyant sur les recommandations
du comité consultatif d'éthique est a
assoupli ses consignes en autorisant
certaines visites notamment
je voulais rappeler également concernant
le confinement que ce confinement des
personnes âgées en ehpad a également été
adopté dans d'autres pays pour sauver
des vies tous les états membres de
l'union européenne à l'exception de la
grèce ou interdits aux visiteurs
d'entrer dans les maisons de retraite
pendant la première phase de la pandémie
et près de la moitié des états membres
ont levé cette interdiction en mai et
les restrictions strictes de visée se
sont poursuivies tout au long du mois de
mai dans sept pays et prolongé ensuite
jusqu'au 31 août
il va falloir conclure la directrice
alors simplement troisième enseignement
qui me semble important de de porter à
votre connaissance
je pense que l'appui sanitaire renforcée
aux établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux a été un acquis absolument
majeur de la crise épidémique et doit
être impérativement pérenniser et enfin
peut-être indiqué que le développement d
partenaire entre l'état et les
collectivités locales reste une autre
réflexion nécessairement approfondir il
me semblait intéressant de le souligner
auprès de vous aujourd'hui
merci merci vous aurez l'occasion de
développer lors des questions monsieur
mais verte
monsieur mais verte allez-y si je peux
me permettre on dit mais vaart excusez
moi monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs donc je représente la lafam
codante la fédération française des
associations de mes cinq ordinateurs en
ehpad qui est la fédération historique
qui regroupe les associations médecin
coordonnateur au niveau national ça date
de 2006
je me suis je me présente à vous
aujourd'hui en tant que vice-président
de la femme qu à la demande donc de
notre présidente nathalie maubourguet
comme président aussi de l'association
des médecins coordonnateurs en ehpad
d'alsace et à ce titre donc
notre association locale a été
particulièrement touché par ce tsunami
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle aussi à
titre personnel en tant que médecin
coordonnateur c'est vrai que j'ai vécu
des périodes extrêmement douloureuses
extrêmement difficile je suis par
ailleurs aussi médecin généraliste alors
ça permettra peut-être aussi de devoir
un petit peu comment ça s'est passé sur
les deux bancs donc à la fois du côté
des médecins coordonnateurs en ehpad et
des médecins généralistes donc en ville
donc un véritable tsunami qui nous et
qui nous a submergé à partir de fin
février sur touts débuts début mars
et nous avons l'impression que les
autorités avaient chaque fois un train
de retard en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne nous avons sentiment alors
après ça peut être profiter aux autres
régions à d'autres partis donc de de la
nation avec nos expériences nos
expériences ils ont été parfois
malheureuses qui ont été parfois
heureuse avec des solutions qu'on a pu
trouver en urgence et qui ont été
reprises par la suite au niveau national
ou dans d'autres régions
je dois dire que pour nous c'était
quelque chose de totalement inimaginable
ça faisait longtemps qu'on se préparer à
ce genre de scénario mais on n'a jamais
pensé que cela pouvait revêtir une telle
une telle gravi une gravité une telle
vitesse surtout ne s'était explosifs
comme comme déroulement donc quelque
chose de totalement inattendu c'est
parti donc de la région de mulhouse en
ce qui nous concerne et sa déferler
ensuite en remontant vers le nord du
haut rhin vers le bas rhin et très vite
plein plein plein de questions se sont
posées comment travailler comment
affronter ce genre de d'épidémie avec
quels équipements puisque nous étions
totalement démunis les plus chanceux
d'entre nous qui allait garder les
équipements de la pandémie et enfin donc
de 2009 h1n1 avaient la chance d'avoir
des masques mais pas les autres il y a
beaucoup de médecins et de professions
de santé qui se sont explosés sans
protection correcte et que
malheureusement qu'ils ont payés parfois
de leur vie
une maladie qui nous faisait pose la
question des symptômes aussi voilà on a
dû tout inventé on a entendu pendant
deux mois par les de la fièvre de la
toux et la disney alors qu on allait
comme des symptômes beaucoup plus varié
qui qui
conques ont observé des personnes âgées
qui se retrouvaient faible qui avait des
signes digestifs qui chute et qui
perdait donc leur autonomie qui on l'a
su après perdez aussi leur odorat lors
le goût
donc c'est quelque chose qui est devenu
très spécifique de cette pathologie
tout ça nous a menés à fermer en très
vite c'est quelque chose que j'avais
demandé au niveau de hauts niveaux de
l'alsace de fermer avant les directives
officielles de fermer les ehpad des
ehpad on a voulu en faire une forteresse
pour éviter que le virus ne pénètre dans
nos établissements pour nous à partir du
moment où le virus était présent dans
l'établissement
la cause était perdue il ya eu ensuite
tout un effet domino qui est lié aussi à
la problématique du too 15,1
quand vous avez des symptômes fait le 15
ça a mis pratiquement tous les médecins
généralistes une grande partie en tout
cas au chômage technique et je pense que
c'était une erreur
une grosse erreur et on aurait pu avoir
beaucoup plus de bras si les médecins
généralistes avaient pu travailler dans
dans ce cadre là
le centre 15 qui en plus s'est retrouvée
submergée complètement dépassés très
très vite et quand on voulait faire
appel à lui que ce soit le particulier
le médecin ou les ehpad on se retrouvait
avec des quarts d'heure des heures j'ai
des pointes à 3 heures d'attentes pour
avoir quelqu'un qui répondent au centre
15 67
le premier message qu'on a reçues des
autorités en tout cas qui en a marqué
plus
plusieurs parmi nous c'était de nous
préparer à l'accompagnement de fin de
vie
un message un petit peu inquiétant vous
conviendrez
nous on avait quand même plutôt envie
est de sauver nos personnes âgées et non
pas d accompagner dignement
même si ça fait partie de notre métier
dans leur fin de vie on a recherché des
soutiens dans tous les sens j'ai passé
un coup de fil phénoménal uni manon de
compte il fenomeno ni au début du mois
de mars pour avoir du soutien au niveau
de spécialisation domicile des soins
palliatifs des équipes mobiles de
gériatrique des autorités aussi des
conseils départementaux pour faire appel
à du personnel de soutien surtout qu'il
y avait quand même pas mal de personnel
de ces services qui étaient fermées en
tout ce qui est la petite enfance
l'éducation nationale etc la rs aussi
donc on est un petit peu on avait
l'impression de crier dans le désert
et finalement c'est par le biais de
l'union régionale des médecins libéraux
que on a eu accès à
on a une voix au chapitre aussi donc
auprès de la rs on a pu commencer à
travailler avec les avec notre adresse
donc la mairesse des ventes est à partir
de mi mars
heureusement ils ont été à l'écouté en
particulier le dg ars de l'époque et on
a pu commencer à travailler ensemble et
à faire valoir des protocoles conte sur
lesquels on avait déjà travaillé nous
mêmes et qu'on a pu faire remonter à ce
moment là au niveau de la région mais
aussi au niveau national il y a
d'ailleurs un guide qui a été édité fin
fin mars par la femme qu et qui a été
mise à disposition pour le grand test
dès la troisième semaine de mars et
après un peu plus tard au niveau
national
les tests oui sont arrivés très tard on
a eu les tout premiers trois semaines
après le début de
de la pandémie donc et puis en plus
façon parcimonieuse c'était de trois
tests pas plus par fois par semaine on
s'est rendu compte très vite au cycle
isolement des personnes âgées entraîner
d'autres problèmes d'autres
problématiques les troubles du
comportement ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome de glissement donc des
personnes qui ont perdu en autonomie ou
parfois même malheureusement qu'ils sont
décédées du fait de l'isolément qui leur
a été imposée et ensuite à contrario
quelques semaines plus tard on s'est vu
confronté à une ouverture une
réouverture des ehpad qui était assez
brutal on a pris sa part voit par la
télé donc un dimanche soir et c'était
pour le lendemain matin c'est vrai que
ça a été souvent assez mal vécue aussi
par par mes confrères et par les chefs
d'établissement le personnel a été
exemplaire ça a été extrêmement durs
ouais je termine traces merci ça est
extrêmement dur ils n'ont pas compté
leurs heures ils ont renoncé aux congés
certains comme vous l'avez vu ou entendu
ce sont sont restés dans l'ehpad pour
éviter de santé donc se sont privés de
leurs familles de leurs proches dans des
conditions tellement difficile pour eux
ils sont aujourd'hui encore épuisé il
les congés d'été souvent n'ont pas suffi
à leur redonner de la force et je
voulais vous faire part aussi de notre
inquiétude qui est toujours présente
nous avons vraiment peur tous ceux qui
ont été fortement impactés
confrontés à cette situation nous avons
vraiment peur de la suite et je me tiens
à votre disposition bien sûr pour vos
questions merci beaucoup merci monsieur
rizo mais j'étais président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs d'abord merci de nous donner
la parole donnée parole par mon
intermédiaire amis aux 1200 directeurs
et directrices adhérents à notre
fédération la fnadepa directeur d'ehpad
directeur de résidence conomie de
résidence seniors et de services à
domicile
jacques sorrel en propos liminaire sur
trois points principaux le premier ce
sont les difficultés rencontrées certain
nombre de termes hockey
je rappellerai en effet à quel point
nous sommes nous avons débuté cette
guerre de manière parfaitement démunis
les carences en termes de masques en
termes d'équipement et les carences
également le thème de test mon collègue
vient de l'évoquer ont été l'une des
causes certaines des difficultés du
début de cette crise non nos adhérents
qui ont subi de hellas de nombreux décès
dans parmi les résidents n'ont pas pu
s'équiper n'ont pas pu lutter
efficacement et malheureusement on sait
aujourd'hui que la ou les décès ont été
les plus nombreux là où les mabouls
aidera monde étaient les plus nombreux
c'est parce que nous avons été pris de
court ça a été évoqué meda soudaineté de
cette pandémie était évidemment l'une
des raisons est et expliquent largement
cette cette difficulté les difficultés
rencontrées elle touche au delà des épis
au delà des tests elle touche aussi aux
effets du confinement nul doute que est
en tout cas c'est notre avis il n'y
avait pas d'autre solution que de pour
protéger nos aînés que de mettre en
oeuvre sur ce confinement
il était indispensable de le faire est
nul dans les établissements et services
de la fed de bon coeur nul ne l'a fait
de bon gré mais chacun a été contraint
de le faire pour justement mettre en
oeuvre et enrayer cette épidémie qui on
l'a vu et on le sait a frappé les plus
âgés de nos concitoyens et puis un autre
des difficultés rencontrées il a encore
pascal mais bart viennent y faire
allusion c'est la question du des
cafouillages dans la communication il y
a eu pendant cette période et notamment
autour de la question de la réouverture
des établissements autour de la question
de la fermeture autour de certains
nombre de points quelques cafouillages
entre la communication politique et la
réalité des protocoles et forcément ça
aussi ça a construit pour nos directeurs
ou directrices des incertitudes des
doutes et des difficultés je crois qu'on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui terre ces
réalités d'un
et je veux dire aussi à quel point en
effet les fédérations et la dgcs merci
mme la directrice ont été parfaitement
en osmose dans la construction de ces
protocoles lionel 35
je dis pas de bêtises et 35 protocole en
aussi peu de temps c'est une vraie vraie
vrai c'était essentiel aussi pour nos
directeurs ou directrices que d'avoir ce
cadre là c'était essentiel mon deuxième
aspect ce sont les forces qui se sont
révélés pendant cette crise il continue
d'ailleurs à se révéler ses forces elles
tiennent d'abord à des organisations qui
ont su s'adapter qui ont su être mobile
qui ont su vivre je parle ici des
organisations au sein des établissements
je ne sais pas d'où ce n'est les
économies au sein des services à
domicile
je parle de l'organisation qui parfois
passé nous semblait impossible et qui
ont été possibles je pense aux
animations très individualisé je pense à
la numérique qui sait aux dunes au
numérique qui s'est mise en oeuvre de
façon extraordinaire dans les ehpad jeu
chacun a pu continuer à garder un
contact même incertain et même si un
satisfaisant avec ses avec sa famille
via des tablettes numériques
c'était évidemment pas aussi bien que
que que de se voir et de se serrer dans
les bras mais ça a été aussi des
évolutions qui ont pu se mettre en
oeuvre de manière parfaitement efficace
et ça c'est un point très important et
ça s'est mis en oeuvre pour aussi parce
que cette adaptation les équipes ont su
les mettre en oeuvre les professionnels
de l'ensemble des professionnels des
directrices bien sûr que je représente
mais l'ensemble des professions des
établissements a réussi à mettre en
oeuvre ces nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement et d'organisation des
collaborations madame lacerda dit qu'ils
se sont mises en oeuvre sur beaucoup de
territoires entre le sanitaire et le
médico social mais aussi entre les
établissements et les services à
domicile on a vu des opportunités qui se
voir le jour parce qu'il ya eu en temps
de crise il ya des souplesses que ne
permet que qui doivent se poursuivre au
delà de cette période
et puis aussi une vraie vision
je crois qu'il s'est amélioré de la
question du grand âge la question de
l'accompagnement du grand âge dans notre
société il ya là quelque chose sur
lequel
on a vu des moments de solidarité avec
des artisans qui ont porté des plaines
pleine décroissance certain nombre de
réalités autour de la place de nos aînés
et la place aussi des ehpad des
établissements dans cette dans la vision
de notre société
le troisième aspect que je veux
développer de manière assez rapide pour
rester dans le temps imparti ce sont les
enjeux et les perspectives
bien évidemment aucun des directeurs
d'ehpad aujourd'hui que je représente ou
de services à domicile ou de résidence
aux nominés persuadé que la crise soit
derrière nous personne aujourd'hui et on
voit bien il y avait quelques
établissements qui sont obligés pour
confiner même partiellement quelques
émissions janvier de nouveaux de réduire
la question des visites en tout cas de
l'encadrer tels que le protocole était
mise en oeuvre parce que des cadres
vides réapparaît s'ils sont un peu
différents on y reviendra sans doute
mais réapparaissent aujourd'hui dans
certains établissements et l'enjeu les
prospectives
je crois qu'on ne peut pas faire
abstraction de la situation d'avant
qu'ovide nos établissements nos ehpad
manqué et manque encore de
professionnels et il faut forcément et
nécessairement que nous sortirons de
cette crise là avec un dispositif qui
soit un dispositif rénové avec plus de
professionnels mieux rémunéré et fort
mais différemment
la crise a laissé apparaître des
capacités de finalement de faire un peu
explosé les silos entre soignants et non
soignants
la crise a révélé par exemple que les
psychologues en établissements étaient
des postes des fonctions essentielles si
elles l'étaient pendant la crise elles
le sont aussi en dehors la crise donc il
faut travailler aussi à des nouvelles
formes de faire un nouveau modalités de
formation autour pour nous
professionnels
il faut simplifier jeudi pendant la
crise on a eu mis en oeuvre on a réussi
à mettre en oeuvre des moyens très
rapide parce qu'il y avait une
simplification il faut que nous
puissions simplifiée aussi un certain
nombre de fonctionnement et puis enfin
mettre en oeuvre des politiques
d'autonomie plus forte et qu'il faut
rénover et sa nombre de travaux qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre et sur lesquels
vous serez saisi mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs va nous nous conduiront
sans doute à rénover
c'est politique de l'autonomie et c'est
notamment autour du grand âge mais on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui imaginer construire
une politique de donner plus forte sur
la base de dix mois qui financent et je
te dirai si tu as droit une prime ou pas
ça n'est pas possible c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui d'imaginer que lorsque vous
êtes salarié d'un ehpad vous puissiez
toucher une prime
évidemment parfaitement légitime même si
ce n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la
situation et de la réforme nécessaire et
quand si vous êtes dans une résidence
tonomy sans forfait soins vous ne
touchez pas cette prime là parce que
vous avez accompagné pareil et souvent
les mêmes catégories de population donc
cette construction là cette gouvernance
là il vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
président tout à l'heure la question de
la gouvernance du secteur là nous pour
nous ne peut pas rester en l'état
en conclusion vraiment très rapide très
très rapide vous allez voir le grand
rendez vous c'est pour maintenant nous
pensons que cette crise là n est
évidemment pas tout à fait terminé mais
qu'elle doit être
et quelle a été révélatrice d'un certain
nombre de lacunes et que ces lacunes là
dedans se transformer de manière durable
dans une grande loi merci merci monsieur
champvert même si ce même temps merci
monsieur le président je fais démarrer
mon chrono bêtes pour essayer de tenir
pile dans le temps là des pattes de moss
et 2000 adhérents directeur
d'établissement de services à domicile
de coordination publics associatifs
commercial et moi même je dirige des
établissements aidés à ce et des
services à domicile dans le secteur
public et associatif
premier élément
moi je serai pas le procureur de l'état
pendant la crise ni du ministre ligier
véran encore mois de la directrice
virginie la serre ni du cabinet du
ministre
bien sûr qu'il ya eu des cafouillages
bien sûr qu'il y avait des messages
contradictoires entre le ministère et
les high rise d'une adresse à l'autre
bien sûr qu'il ya eu des changements de
positions mais c'est le propre d'une
période de crise
et ces cafouillages que nous avons pu
renvoyer à la directrice de la cohésion
sociale parce qu'il fallait les régler
mais on peut pas reprocher qu'il y ait
eu tout ça parce que c'est inévitable et
nous mêmes en position de responsabilité
nous avons aussi dit un truc puis le
contraire pu avancer pire que les pions
savait pas parce que c'est un tsunami le
ciel nous est tombé sur la tête enfin
tout le monde a été saisi d'effroi par
ce qui nous arrive est et moi je tiens à
dire ici au fortement et ceux qui me
connaissent savent que les compliments
dans ce genre d'exercice c'est pas
forcément ma tasse de thé préférées je
tiens à remercier la directrice de la
cohésion sociale de toutes les réunions
qu'elle a organisée et de son écoute et
je sais qu'on n'a pas toujours été
d'accord et dieu sait qu'on a discuté
qu'on a débattu mais on s'est toujours
sentie écoutée et aussi par le cabinet
du ministre olivier ferrand je je je
tiens à le dire
alors la crise c'est un moment où le
passé présente sa note alors je vais pas
trop développées au fond la période de
la crise plus avant puisque mes
collègues l'ont largement fait moi je
voudrais développer un peu de quoi le
coronavirus est le révélateur
d'abord le le coronavirus il a confirmé
il a rendu plus visite plus visible par
dont les richesses jean-pierre à raison
les richesses du secteur et puis le
dysfonctionnement fondamentale du
secteur français des deux personnes
âgées les richesses boss c'est d'abord
les salariés
il faut leur rendre hommage comme cela a
été fait pour leur engagement
mais attention c'est une richesse qui
s'épuise et j'y reviendrai et je partage
qu'elle dit pascal may vaart s'est aussi
les résidents et il faudra s'appuyer
beaucoup plus sur eux dans l'avenir et
on ne l'a pas assez fait dans la période
et puis bien entendu les familles sur
lesquels aussi on peut s'appuyer une
fois qu'on a écouté les résidents ça
c'est les richesses le reste basse et
les dysfonctionnements profond du
système alors je commencerai rapidement
par le domicile balleux domicile celle
secteur invisible
les personnes sont invisibles on ne sait
pas on le sait depuis à peine une
semaine combien de personnes sont
décédées à domicile mais on ne sait
toujours
aujourd'hui qui sont les gens qui sont
décédés à l'hôpital et moi je fais le
pari qu'on va découvrir dans les mois
qui viennent la même chose que pendant
la canicule de 2003 pendant que l'équipe
de 2003 on a hyper focaliser sur les
établissements on s'est rendu compte que
la moitié des décès était aussi à
domicile et ce sera sans doute la même
chose dans ce cas précis le domicile est
paré dans l'inconscient collectif de
toutes les vertus
mais il est encore plus déconsidérés que
les établissements très concrètement
c'est un sous-financement encore plus
important ce sont des personnes âgées
isolées ce sont des secteurs des
services dans lesquels les personnes
sont cantonnés à une réponse purement
physiques ont fait le ménage on nettoie
le corps on s'occupe pas de l'affectif
née du psychique ni du coeur ni de l'un
ni de la tête
et puis c'est des salariés encore plus
sous payés et encore plus sous qualifié
la sphère de la prime l'a bien montré
c'est une prime en deux temps elle se
sera pas tout de suite ça a été annoncé
en août et puis c'est on sait pas
éventuellement et puis c'est les
derniers qui ont été servis en masque
qui est responsable de cela l'état et
les départements l'état qui refuse
d'agréer les augmentations de salaires à
travers les conventions collectives dans
la principale convention collective et
les départements qui demande qu'il n'y
ait pas trop de personnel qualifié parce
que sinon ça augmente les dépenses
s'agissant de l'aide aux personnes âgées
globalement en france c'est un
dysfonctionnement dont tout le monde
s'habitue nous à l'ad-pa nous ne nous
résignons pas ses 10000 morts chaque
année de la grippe
ses 3000 morts chaque année en moyenne
de la canicule et ça est à peu près 20
milles du corps et navires us que dirait
ton si c'était dix mille enfants de
moins de 10 ans qui mouraient chaque
année alors les raisons de fond le
problème majeur c'est l'âgisme
je développe pas je vous renvoie à
l'excellent rapport de votre collègue
député audrey du feu jubeir ce qui est
normal c'est d'être hagist ce qui est
anormal c'est de ne pas l'être
on lutte de mieux en mieux contre toutes
les discriminations dans notre pays le
problème de l'âgisme c'est qu'on ne leur
père pas et l'âgisme c'est quoi on
dévalorise les besoins des personnes
on ne l'est concentre que sur le
physique à bien manger c'est tout ce qui
leur reste comme si un être humain se
résumer à ça on ne s'occupe pas de leur
liberté pas de leur citoyenneté
et tout cela est porté par ce que notre
vision du monde allait porter par notre
façon de nommer les choses c'est porté
par un vocabulaire dans lequel on parle
en permanence de dépendance pour les
cantonner à une situation d'assisté est
pas une situation de citoyens et on leur
refuse le terme d'autonomie sinon pour
parler de pertes
je vous rappelle que vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale en 2001 lors de la
loi autonomie ont voté à l'unanimité un
amendement d'un député de l'opposition
qui proposait qu'on supprime dépendance
du de la loi est d'ailleurs dans la loi
autonomie dans la loi pas jamais il n'ya
dépendance pourquoi on continue à parler
de dépendance parce qu'il ya un décret
qui a était paru qui était paru un peu
avant et qui ne parlent que de tout cela
donc très très rapidement dans les
établissements on est dans un système à
bout parce qu'on est dans une logique
hyper sécuritaire et on a eu du
déchaînement hyper sécuritaire pendant
cette crise il faut le reconnaître
alors bien sûr il y avait beaucoup de
peur bien sûr il y avait beaucoup de
professionnels extrêmement engagée qui
voulait faire le maximum mais comme dit
le proverbe quand tu fais sans moi tu
fait contre moi et donc il faudra dans
l'avenir mais j'y reviendrais donner
beaucoup plus la parole aux personnes
âgées très bien mais maintenant nous
allons donner la parole aux rapporteurs
oui non
excusez moi je suis intervenu au team
adam leur nom à présenter d'après lors
des questions vous pourrez répondre à
titre liminaire si une intervention de
cinq minutes pour chacune des
représentations d'accord mais vous aurez
l'occasion je pense de répondre à des
questions
donc je passe la parole au
haut-commissaire et nous allons aller
dans leur bernard jomier présente ses
questions et nous dit à qui elle
s'adresse
merci monsieur le président je vous
permettra un propos liminaire pour que
pour qu'on se mettre bien d'accord entre
nous parce que madame la directrice vous
nous avez un peu rappelé à l'ordre en
disant n'oublions pas qu'il est
difficile de juger a posteriori ce qu'il
a été fait on n'est pas là pour juger
nous on n'est pas un tribunal on est là
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé pour
essayer de tirer des leçons et pas à
titre individuel sur ce que tel ou tel
acteur a fait il ya eu des énumérations
d'acteurs qui ont été prononcées par par
des personnes qui vient de s'exprimer
mais pour comprendre quels sont les
mécanismes qui font qu' il ya eu autant
de décès en l'occurrence en l'occurrence
dans les ehpad et donc on n'est
certainement pas dans le jugement mais
on n'est pas plus je tiens à le dire
dans le de toute façon c'est inévitable
ya des dysfonctionnements et puis un
risque qu'un c'est vrai et donc ça n'est
pas une sagesse ça pour moi c'est plus
une forme d'impuissance théorisé ça
n'est pas plus satisfaisant donc et si
on nous met sur une voie médiane et de
comprendre comment on aurait pu faire
mieux parce que si on est des
responsables publics tous les uns et les
autres c'est pour pour tenter de faire
mieux
vous nous avez dit madame la directrice
du synerpa vous aviez écrit agnès buzyn
début février et que vous n'aviez pas eu
de pas eu de réponse dont je pense à
agnès buzyn est largement chargé par un
certain nombre de personnes pour le coup
mais j'ai envie de moi de vous retourner
la question
bon et alors qu'avez vous fait à ce
moment là d'ailleurs c'est ont dit oui
mais j'ai écrit à la ministre
puis la mini ça m'a pas répondu alors du
coup on reste les bras n'êtes pas rester
bras croisés parce que vous êtes une
actrice et donc au mois de février quand
vous avez compris qu'ils se passait à un
problème puisque ce qu'on a on entend
bien des différentes auditions qu'on a
mené depuis le mois de juillet c'est que
dès fin janvier
des alertes ont été données et je crois
qu'un des groupes votre groupe orpea
très vite en fin janvier a commencé à se
préoccuper de la situation sur la base
d'informations qu'il obtenait d'autres
pays donc au mois de février
forcément vous êtes entrés en action et
donc le temps le temps à avancer et moi
il ya une question que je voudrais quand
même comprendre on a auditionné le
directeur médical du samu de
seine-et-marne et il explique que en
avril à en février en mars
en avril ils réalisent lors d'une
intervention dans un ehpad qui est des
personnes âgées qui meurent n'ont pas dû
qu'au ville mais de déshydratation et
donc ils décident y met en place un
protocole de visite systématique de tous
les résidents des ehpad de son ressort
et ses équipes trouvent un certain
nombre de personnes âgées qui sont
déshydratés qui ne prennent plus leurs
traitements qui sont défaut de soins et
pour certaines on décède pour d'autres
seront sauvés un peu in extremis comment
est-ce que comment est ce qu'on peut
expliquer cette situation au mois
d'avril c'est ce que nous essayons de
comprendre c'est comment bien sûr les
incertitudes et début de l'épidémie etc
on les connaît tous on
un petit peu de mémoire mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé à ce moment là dans les
ehpad
est-ce qu'on manquait de personnel est
ce que les personnels étaient un peu
comme l'a expliqué monsieur chambert je
pense tétanisés par ce déchaînement de
fait peur en fait cette atmosphère de
peur qui avaient envahi le manque de
moyens de protection donc on se met on
se met en retrait on ne pense plus qu'à
se sauver si qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec ce discours sur l'isolément aussi
que je ne remets pas en cause non plus
le fait qu'on est isolé au mois de mars
les personnes âgées au maroc mars avril
en fonction des connaissances du moment
mais qu est ce qui a produit ce qui est
manifestement a été quand même une
situation où un certain nombre de
personnes âgées en ehpad se sont
retrouvés en défaut de prise en charge
avec des conséquences qui sont lourdes
à moins que vous contestez ce constat
mais à ce moment là il va falloir nous
l'argumenter remercie on s'adresse
précisément où synerpa qui répond j'ai
eu une phrase pour dire qu'effectivement
je ne vois pas du tout quoi il s'agit
par rapport à la déshydratation vous
faites état je vais vous préciser donc
c'était le docteur dolbec explique que
en se rendant en visite
appelés pour un cas dans un ehpad où il
y avait eu des décès en voyant les
résidents il se rend compte que des
résidents sont déshydratés etc
ce n'est pas un exemple isolé puisque
d'abord un protocole a été mis en place
pour visiter l'ensemble des résidents de
l'ehpad du ressort et que les cas trouvé
ont été assez nombreux et par ailleurs
des témoignages indiquent que ça s'est
répétée sur d'autres territoires donc si
vous vous pouvez tout à fait nous
expliquer pardon ça a été déclaré sous
serment donc vous pouvez nous expliquer
que à votre connaissance d'antan il n'y
a pas eu ce type de cas où cet été
entamées avec totti qu on essaye nous de
comprendre moi voilà en tout cas c'est
évidemment à l'issue de la crise
déshydratation de certains résidents au
mois d'avril c'est pas quelque chose qui
nous est remonté comme étant un
phénomène des fautes soin de prise en
charge non plus mais bon je préfère à la
limite passer la parole effectivement un
opérateur qui lui avait a été sur le sur
le sur le terrain je vous permettez
monsieur le président je vais essayer de
vous répondre j'aime bien que ce soit
plutôt quelque chose de médical je ne
suis pas docteur de formation que
j'essaie de vous répondre
pour éviter tout petit propos j'ai pas
pu m'exprimer tout à l'heure en quelques
phrases simplement ce que représente
orpea est bon et ma fonction afin que
vous ayez un éclairage complet orfella
comprend un peu plus de 1000
établissements répartis dans dans plus
de 20 pays et 3 continents soit 104 midi
à peu près dont 20000 en construction et
65 mille cinq cents salariés à peu près
dans le dans les pays où nous sommes
présents nous intervenons sur cinq types
de métiers le moyen séjour en clinique
et ses serres et nous allons nous en
reparlerons après justement dans la
continuité des soins et la psychiatrie
les ehpad les soins domiciliaire et dans
ce service en france je je je je vais je
vais vous répondre et je voulais tout
simplement vous vous présenter en france
nous avons 18 mille cinq cents lits en
ehpad
concernant concernant votre question
quand la décision a été prise de
confiner dans les établissements il ya
un certain nombre de évidemment de
personnes qui étaient confrontés à l'
isolement plus ou moins bien gérés par
des équipes en ce qui nous concerne nous
n'avons pas eu à relever ce type de
déshydratation sommes très peu
d'établissements présent en
seine-et-marne
je dirige l'ensemble des dpi je dirais
précisément dans le questionnaire que
nous établissions seine-et-marne et je
vous ferai leurs relevés précis de ce
type 2 et altérations que nous avons été
confrontés si toutefois nous avons été
confrontés mais ça peut tout à fait
arrivée vous pouvez avoir un manque de
personnel sur un ou quelques
établissements qui ont été
particulièrement exposés avec beaucoup
de personnel vacant un soignant là pour
le coup est donc moins de visites dans
les champs et il est possible qu
effectivement certains résidants étaient
atteints de symptômes déshydratation
c'est ce que vous me dites me semble
tout à fait logique
ça ressemble s'assemble tout à fait
probable nous n'avons pas nous étaient
confrontés à ce type de problématique
vous n'avez pas connaissance dans vos
réseaux de défaut est le cas je peux
vous présenter pour que ce soit tout à
fait pour ce soit tout à fait clair la
crise nous nous l'avons vécu plutôt fin
mars
pourquoi parce que nous avions des hauts
pays à disposition je pourrais vous
expliquer pourquoi après si on pose la
question
non vous avons pris des mesures très tôt
en fait vers saint février évidemment se
pardonner mais rappelez moi je n'avais
pas connaissance d'eux excusez-moi de
type de ce type de problématique dans
les établissements non nous n'avions pas
connaissance de ce type de projet est
inondée et des licences n'est pas
remonté par la direction médicale très
clairement mais je vous ferai un point
très particulier sur les tables rondes
seine-et-marne je crois pas qu'il soit
très nombreux dans ce réseau merci
monsieur mais verte oui alors je voulais
prendre donner un petit point de vue
médical on a eu des retours
un autre niveau donc plutôt de deux
problèmes de dénutrition de perte de
poids pas tellement de j'ai pas eu de
retour par rapport à des soucis
déshydratation et en fait on s'est rendu
compte que c'était plutôt dans des
établissements qui étaient déjà sous
dotées au niveau personnel auparavant et
qui ont du fait de la crise
l'absentéisme ou de l'absence de
renforts se sont retrouvés donc avec
moins de personnel à devoir apporter les
repas en chambre puisqu'il n'y avait
plus de malades europe a pris en salle
de restauration dont quelque chose qui
prend beaucoup plus de temps avec moins
de personnel et donc le constat les
établissements où il ya eu du renfort en
personnel
ils n'ont pas été confrontés à ce genre
de problématique
cette problématique s'est retrouvé
vraiment dans des établissements qui est
en grande difficulté au niveau personnel
merci monsieur champvert poste
et si physiquement sur la déshydratation
mais y at il des défauts de soins dans
les établissements oui évidemment il y
en a t'il à domicile oui évidemment les
retards de la france par rapport à ses
principaux voisins européens sont bien
connus quand philippe bas et ministre de
la chargée de l'aide aux personnes âgées
notamment son premier ministre dominique
de villepin avait annoncé c'était en
2006 qu'il faudrait huit professionnels
pour 10 personnes âgées dans les
établissements en 2012
nous sommes huit ans après on devait à 8
pour 10 on est à 6 pour dix bons et
philippe bas et dominique de villepin
avait raison de dire cela donc le retard
est totale
nous n'avons qu'un seul espoir je ne
développe pas plus c'est que dans les
établissements comme dans les services à
domicile la loi autonomie la nomination
de la ministre brigitte bourguignon soit
l'occasion enfin de donner les moyens
aux établissements aux services à
domicile d'accompagner correctement les
personnes âgées
j'ai parlé dans les établissements de
l'objectif qui est mauvais parce qu'il
est essentiellement sécuritaire j'ai dit
qu'à domicile l'objectif est mauvais
parce qu'il est essentiellement centré
sur le corps mais il faut bien entendu
ajouter à cela le manque de
professionnels dans les établissements
et dans les services à domicile et dans
l'urgence je reviens sur ce qu'a dit
pascal meinhard tout à l'heure dans
l'urgence il faut renforcer les équipes
avec des psys avec des emplois aidés
avec des créations d'emplois ce serait
d'ailleurs peut-être une une réponse au
chômage qui pointe le nez parce que moi
je suis assez effaré dans les équipes
que je dirige
je pensais qu'avec l'aide psychologique
qu'on a pu leur apporter
je pensais qu'avec les vacances on
aurait encore des choses à gérer
je suis étonné du nombre de
professionnels qui ne vont pas bien et
de gens qui disent il ya eu la prime en
établissement il faut reconnaître que ça
c'est positif
c'est une catastrophe à domicile mais en
établissement ça a été bien accueilli et
ça a été positif mais il faut
reconnaître quand même que l'épuisement
est telle que les gens disent moi j'y
étais la fois d'avant la fois d'après
j'y serai pas donc il ya urgence
il ya un besoin de renfort d'urgence
sans attendre la loi et après on compte
sur vous et vos collègues députés pour
la loi monsieur rizo pour complet très
rapidement pour dire évidemment que je
suis parfaitement en accord parce que
vient de dire pascal champvert et
rajouter que je disais tout à l'heure
pour préliminaire que nous sommes pas
sortis de la crise et que certain nombre
d'établissements
aujourd'hui hélas sont frappés par la
par le virus ça veut dire que ce que
veut dire pascal est d'autant plus
important d'arriver à construire des
solutions même temporaire même
transitoire très rapidement parce que au
fond je sais pas si une deuxième vague
j'en sais rien mais ce que je sais c'est
que il ya des établissements qui jusqu'à
présent n'avait pas été concernée dans
des territoires qui jusqu'à présent
étaient des territoires plutôt ouvert je
pense notamment à ma région d'occitanie
et qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus en verre
je pense aux départements du gard et de
l'hérault par exemple et on voit à quel
point l'usure et la fatigue des équipes
et une finalement que un rebond dans
l'établissement aujourd'hui peut avoir
des effets absolument désastreux sur ce
que vous évoquez monsieur le sénateur
dire qu'il ya des défauts de soins c'est
quand même grave vous avez ces remonte
également au niveau de votre fédération
non non non on avant tout cas c'est
parce qu'ils nous à ce qui nous est
apparu vivace au mois d'avril clairement
en mars avril ce qui est vivace c'est
plus lutter contre le coc vide et
essayer de faire en sorte que le
confinement en chambre soit le moins
délétère possible bien sûr tous les
hôpitaux les cliniques ont eu des soins
repoussé donc dé perdre et des résidents
ont eu beaucoup de soin repoussé pendant
deux mois
aucun professionnel extérieur n'est venu
et on ne pouvait transférer orco vide
quasiment personne dans le milieu
sanitaire donc de toutes façons comme
dans la population générale
bien sûr l'ensemble des traitements a
parfois pris deux à trois mois de retard
donc oui forcément
la prise en charge en soins étaient
dégradées mais ce qui nous est apparu à
ce moment là c'est l'investissement des
salariés qui malgré tout ont tout donné
pour être présent au chevet des
résidents d'ailleurs on a des taux
d'absentéisme de moitié pendant cette
période paradoxalement avec donc des
salariés qui se sont coûte que coûte
démener pour être présent donc c'est
difficile d'évoquer des défauts de soins
à ce moment là dans le cadre dans lequel
nous étions en tout cas sylvie
vermeillet merci monsieur le président
j'aurai une question madame la
directrice générale de la cohésion
sociale dans le cadre de cette
commission d enquête le 8 juillet nous
avons entendu monsieur lannelongue
ex-directeur de la rs du grand est il a
déclaré que concernant les ehpad
il avait vécu une période aveugle
jusqu'au 20 mars et qu'il ne disposait
pas de système d'information alors
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
éclairer sur ce dysfonctionnement et
nous dire en cas de deuxième vague ce
que ce que vous avez modifié dans le
fonctionnement pour que ces périodes
aveugle disparaissent merci merci madame
la directrice
posez une question qui est effectivement
crucial qui est celle du suivi de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
quelles que soient les champs concernés
effectivement je le redis nous avons
avancé en marchant néanmoins il faut
avoir en tête que nous réunissions en
tout cas la direction générale de la
santé avec le secrétaire général des
ministères sociaux réunis c'est de façon
au moins bimensuel voir tous les tous
les jours l'ensemble des directeurs
généraux des ars
ce qui permettait de d'être très je
dirais directement en contact avec eux
et de pouvoir à la fois donné des
consignes aux niveaux national et puis
avoir aussi au niveau des des directeurs
généraux des ars une remontée d'un
maximum d'informations
après plusieurs outils ont été mis en
place de façon extrêmement précis un
tableau de bord que la dgcs a mis en
place entre avril et juin qui a permis
la de suivre un certain nombre
d'indicateurs extrêmement précis sur par
exemple le nombre d'astreinte mis en
place mais aussi des indicateurs en
termes épidémique
et puis le 28 mars nous avons oui ça
c'est avril entre avril et juin 2 avril
à juin nous avons mis en place un
tableau de bord extrêmement précis dans
lequel de façon hebdomadaire l'aider les
directeurs généraux des ars nous faisait
remonter un certain nombre de de données
extrêmement précises sur le suivi de
l'épidémie ce qui permettait d'alimenter
aussi toute la réflexion au niveau
national et puis sur les outils
également donc un nouvel outil qui
s'appelle vous à nous qui est une
plateforme gérée par santé publique
france a été mis en place le 28 mars
dernier et permet de suivre très
précisément les décès et les cas qu vide
au sein ddv pad et puis je peux
détailler aussi nous avons mis en place
d'autres outils de suivi comme par
exemple les tests avec une plateforme
qui s'appelle fidhop piloter aussi par
santé publique france et qui permet là
aussi d'avoir en récupérant les
les éléments de l'ensemble des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques d'avoir un
suivi très fin du nombre de tests
réalisés dans les ehpad
merci catherine des roches merci
monsieur le président moi j'entends bien
tout ce que vous avez dit et les
relations qu'ils ont pu être celle en
effet avec la la dgcs de ce que vous
avez vécu ce qui nous manque dans cette
explication c'est vraiment la
chronologie parce que vous nous dites
vous ça a commencé début avril
début avril on est content début avril
ce matin les services à domicile nous
ont dit que le 6 mars il avait une note
disant qu'ils auraient peut-être un
confinement global le jour où président
la république disait qu'on pouvait aller
au cinéma au théâtre au restaurant donc
tout ça est très difficile à comprendre
en termes de cohérence et de décisions
de décision et de messages haineux sage
donnait pour le groupe orpea il a été
précisé dans la presse et veut un
article dans challenges
disons que dès le 21 janvier du fait de
l'expérience des établissements que vous
avez intrants j'ai notamment des
établissements en chine
vous aviez mis en place une cellule de
crise est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
si c'est la réalité et qu'ils étaient
dans cette cellule de crise parce que
vous nous avez parlé vous les
établissements la dgcs mais quelle était
la place des ars quelle était la place
de département et surtout quels étaient
les liens directs lorsque vous aviez
quelque chose qui se passait dans nos
établissements
comment se faisait la remontée au niveau
au niveau central et quelles étaient les
réponses qui vous êtes un apportez moi
je trouve ya un flou dans cette période
qu'est majorque et celle du mois de
février et du début mars et il faudra
vraiment dans leur réponse écrite que
vous nous préciser clairement quand vous
nous dites on avait des réunions
régulières
oui mais à quelle date exactement ça
c'était un point qui est très très
important
et puis vous avez dit monsieur champvert
nos équipes et nos personnels sont en
effet encore très fragile
psychologiquement mais c'est indéniable
qu'il y aura des conséquences
psychosociales majeur parce que vous
avez eu des personnels qui n'était pas
au départ protégez vous vous allez nous
expliquer comment vous avez des
équipements de protection
comment vous les avez obtenu alors que
les autres savaient pas et comment c'est
fait la gestion dans vos établissements
de tous ces décès parce qu'on a des
descriptions de décès avec des
conséquences majeures pour les familles
qui n'avaient pas accès accompagner leur
famille soit en fin de vie lorsqu'elles
étaient décédés comment tout ça c'est
organisé est ce que selon vous un
établissement qui revêtait ce qui aurait
des équipements de protection aurait pu
faire un confinement moins draconien
mercure protéger et à la fois son
personnel et les résidents sans avoir
les conséquences que l'on connaît
actuellement un donc de questions
précises une pour monsieur bré ding dong
moi je ne sais pas si ça fonctionne oui
nous allons prendront pas tout à fait le
même calendrier assure un certain nombre
de points avec le synerpa nous étions
plus dans l'action dans la réflexion
d'abord puis dans l'action et ensuite
transférer les informations synerpa de
façon c'est sa remontée prendre de la
vente sur le sur le déroulement des
faits afin de comprendre la situation
que vous évoquez qui était assez
complexe effectivement entre fin janvier
et elle est le mois de mars courant mars
je voulais vous faire part de 2,2 deux
chiffres tout simplement deux chiffres
qui vont s'éclaircir un peu plus ce qui
nous est arrivé
la moyenne des décès trimestrielle au
premier trimestre 2010 9
donc je parle un an avant premier
trimestre était par mois 2 528 décès par
mois dans les ehpad dans nos états sur
dix-huit mille cinq cents lits à peu
près en france je parle que de la france
je vous parlais de co2 la france
aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien sauf
quand je voudrais qu'on nous avons eu
des alertes à l'étranger
la moyenne trimestrielle donc 528 par
mois en 2010 à la moyenne trimestrielle
sur le premier trimestre 2001 et est de
535 ça veut donc dire qu'on ne savait
pas signifie
hâtif et pourtant si pour nous ça a
commencé à partir du 24 et du 25 mars
je vais revenir là dessus si vous le
permettez on m'avait posé la question
sur la chronologie des faits notamment
nos amis chinois
alors nous avons effectivement une
présence en chine à nankin
d'abord sur la côte est et puis
particulièrement sur sur changsha leur
champ de chasse évoque peut-être pas
grand chose pour vous si ce n'est que
c'est située à 350 km au sud de one la
wii à peu près où ça se trouve désormais
été assez assez assez cartographier et
là le 28 le 28 janvier le 21 pardon le
21 janvier nos équipes basées à shanghai
au siège appelle la direction médicale
du groupe en disant voilà on constate
quelque chose depuis plusieurs jours
qu'il nous semble un peu étonnant plus
d'agitation de la par nos fournisseurs
et puis des visites de notre site par
les autorités de tutelle nous sommes
habitués en chine avoir beaucoup de
visites beaucoup plus qu en europe
pourquoi parce que nous y faisons une
prise en charge qui n'est pas connue
encore en chine et ces gens là arrivent
et pose des questions manifestement plus
liées au métier aux limites de prises en
charge en soins jusqu'où peut-on aller
pour prendre en charge un résident
potentiellement infectées et il parle et
les fournisseurs parle d'infection d'une
d'une famille dérivé du strass bien je
suis informée le 21 le 21 janvier je
suis informé directement par la
directrice médicale ne connaissons
depuis plus de vingt ans tous les deux
on a comme pascal affronter affronter la
canicule en 2003 je pose des question
n'étant pas médecin je pose des
questions basiques pro à le mans candide
c'est à ton un remède
quels sont les symptômes quels sont les
protocoles et on n'a absolument rien je
pose une question en plus c'est ce qu'on
a des signes sur les signes sur les
sites chinois
nous n'avons rien je tiens à vous
signaler madame le rapporteur que nous
avons jamais eu la moindre infection sur
nos chine chinois qui sera celui de 100
chats ou celui de nankin jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc en france le monde en chine on
active la cellule de crise chinoise
immédiatement et en france je demande à
ce qu'on réfléchisse dans un petit
comité composé de médecins avec auquel
on va ajouter un cardiologue de celle où
et en ajoutant aussi le directeur
médical france dont quatre ou cinq
médecins avec des compétences
différentes pour qu'il puisse
m'expliquer les symptômes préparer les
symptômes au cas où ça se passerait mal
quel type de traitement
si on n'a pas de traitement mais on
comprend bien que le problème et médical
il nous faut une réponse
il nous faut forcément une réponse
médicale à un problème médical c'est
hier qu'ont j'anticipe déjà assez
rapidement en discutant avec la
directrice médicale qui va falloir
placer nos équipes en france et à
l'étranger sous les ordres du médical ça
c'est extrêmement important
et puis nous avons besoin effectivement
d'avoir une recherche internationale sur
les réseaux sur les symptômes d'activer
tous nos réseaux sur le plan
international et également les
procédures et je demande trois types de
procédures
c'est un cas classique de gestion de
crise quand on sait qu'une crise peut
potentiellement arriver petit 1 je
demande une procédure sur ça peut
arriver mais ce n'est pas encore présent
sur un territoire donné pour
l'occurrence la france mais ça peut être
l'autriche ou l'allemagne wire petit 2
nous sommes à proximité de ce que les
médias ont appelé un cluster nous
l'avons définie comme étant une région
un territoire donné dans lequel à moins
de 30 kilomètres de notre établissement
du dos l'un de nos établissements qu'ils
soient sanitaires ou médico social en
france
nous nous avions un cluster quelles
mesures sont à prendre
et troisièmement jordi voilà hélas la
situation existe dans l'établissement
quels sont les 3e type de mesures à
prendre nous avons appelée koro un cours
aux deux corps autres en cette période
là elle a daté du 21 janvier au 2 3 mars
pourquoi cette date là tout simplement
parce que nous avons activé le 3 mars la
cellule de crise internationale et nous
avons activé la cellule de crise
françaises le 3 mars précisément à cette
période là quelque chose de très
important pardonnez moi mais nous
n'avions aucun cas ni en france ni
ailleurs
ça c'est extrêmement important
le comprendre ni en france ni ailleurs
je vous rappelle que l' oms a déclaré le
facteur de pandémie le 11 mars seulement
pandémie international toujours pas
d'infection chine une période
d'incrédulité
à partir de fin février jusqu'à mi-mars
celle où j'étais en train de me demander
à titre personnel si j'avais fait un peu
tout ça pour ça ce que j'avais pourrait
pas fait trop finalement on avait des
procédures fin février on les a
transmises évidemment aussi nerpa qui a
immédiatement je laisserais florence
expliqué après réuni une commission
médicale avec les principaux dirigeants
du groupe pour pouvoir échanger sur les
bons protocole cros un corps aux deux
c'est à dire en cas de risque et on a le
risque imminent parce qu'on est à moins
de 30 kilomètres pour nous c'était ce
que nous avions défini toujours pas le
koro 3 que j'ai demandé parce qu'on
n'avait pas de cas ont simplement pas
comment faire à partir du 3 donc c'était
pas la réunion d'olivier ferrand pour le
synerpa mais c'était pour nous la date
de mise en place des deux de ces
cellules de crise à la fois
international et national
alors qu'est ce que nous avons fait
pendant cette première phase et avant le
3 a tout simplement on a regardé les
stocks
pourquoi parce que nous avions une
procédure qui s'appelle ira prévention
des infections respiratoires autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait
communément plus communément la lutte
contre la grippe et donc dans cette
procédure
il est habituel que nous ayons des
masques mais pas que des masques parce
qu'une des questions j'avais posé à
l'équipe était de savoir dans ce petit
comité
quel type de matériel et nous fallait
est ce qu'il nous faut vraiment que des
masques est ce qu'il nous faut vraiment
que des masques et là est venue toute
une série de produits
donc on a regardé quels étaient les les
les quantités stockées ce qui n'était
pas une mince affaire parce qu'ils sont
délégués sur le plan international à
tous les directeurs d'établissement pour
une raison qui est très simple parce
qu'aujourd'hui
et dans cette période avant cette
période là l'approvisionnement est
quasiment automatique vous envoyez un
mail et 48 heures après trois cent douze
heures après vous êtes livré que ce soit
des surblouse des gants etc
vous êtes livré de manière quasi
automatique et là je me disais tiens
avec les médecins manque de chance
si jamais on n'a plus d'après sait
jamais on indiqué
tu es sur les appros est-ce qu'il faut
pas qu'on reprenne la main comment
fait-on pour reprendre la main quand on
n'a pas le système d'approvisionnement
et de comptage des matériels que nous
avons sur les sites c'est un vaste sujet
il faut développer des systèmes
informatiques savent occuper toutes nos
équipes en février pour avoir une vision
très claire de ce que nous avions sur le
plan international en termes de masque
on a mobilisé les achats on a fait les
achats préventif d'abord de ffp2 parce
que nous étions convaincus au médecin
que les zones qu'elles être à risque
nécessité des protections maximales pour
nos salariés maximale et puis ensuite
dès début mars alors que nous ayons pas
de cas nous avons fait une commande
préventive de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de masques r2 dont des masques
chirurgicaux ce que nous portons
aujourd'hui voilà ce que nous avons fait
dans cette première période où il ne
s'est rien passé
deuxième personne deuxième période 3
mars 3 mars jusqu'au 10 mars
rien rien il ne se passe absolument rien
nous avons le connaissance du 10 mars à
l'étranger toujours pas en chine
toujours pas en france
nous avons connaissance le 10 mars d'un
épisode de diarrhée portant sur huit
résidents en italie en lombardie à côté
de milan d'anvers des lots vers le haut
la diarrhée
je parle sous contrôle du docteur
n'était pas un signe décrit comme étant
symptomatique du club il n'a au moins
nous est remonté on suit on suit et le
13 5 personnes décèdent le 12 nous avons
le premier cas et un seul cas sur dix
mille 10 18500 qui est identifié comme
étant covit positif quelques cas
suspects et dérisoire au regard du
nombre de personnes que nous hébergeons
à partir du 24 et du 25
c'est là où nous avons pu commencer à
avoir beaucoup plus de décès 26 décès le
25 mars et +2 je vous donnerai les
chiffres précis
plus de 160 car potentiellement à risque
160 nous passons à 220 cas
potentiellement à risque en une nuit
donc c'est tout ça qui fait qu'en fait
on a pu avoir le matériel assez
rapidement former les gens avec des
hygiénistes toute la période de début
mars et espèce de quinze jours qu'on a
eue de latence former les équipes avec
des hygiénistes qui passait sur le
terrain nous en avons 38 en france c'est
quelque chose nous devons anticiper ya
quelques années et puis de préparer
l'ensemble des protocoles et très
rapidement le 12 mars nous avons eu
cette procédure qui nous fallait et que
nous avons communiqué évidemment on
considère pas sur la façon d'appréhender
avec les premiers cas que nous avions à
la fois d'italie et le premier cas que
nous avions français le la façon de
pouvoir appréhender les choses en ce qui
concerne la prise en charge des
personnes âgées positive voilà c'est
tout pour cet éclairage qui vous
semblait compliqué on te frévrier et
mars
tout ça était une chronologique est
parfaite vous pouvez la suivre date par
date tout est tracé
avec les décès qu'augmenter après
premier trimestre pas d'augmentation des
décès donc des dossiers qu'augmenter et
famars et enfin famars entre le 24 et le
25 c'est là on a eu vraiment le gall
tout à fait pour nous en ce qui nous
concerne nous n'étions pas présents dans
l'est je corrige
nous sommes très peu présents dans l'est
contrairement à certain nombre
d'adhérents du synerpa et contrairement
à ce que vient de dire le donneur c'est
pour ça qu'à l'expérience
voilà merci de ces précisions pour ne
vous en prie cette chronologie elle est
majeure dans la gestion d'examiner la
gestion la crise ce qui serait
intéressant aussi au regard des des
réponses que vous nous avez fait c'est
que on est on est un tableau un peu
récapitulatif des différents
établissements de leur géographie dans
lequel est sûre géographique le nombre
de résidents je sais pas si la dgcs a
fait ou à des stades i c'est comme ça et
devoirs établissement par établissement
le nombre de décès par rapport au nombre
de résidents parce qu'à un moment
peut-être qu'il faudrait sans doute
aller vous faire cette analyse trouver
peut-être des explications aussi
pourquoi dans tel cas il ya eu plus de
17 ans de bon il ya aussi le
la typologie du résident selon là selon
la comorbidité autres et c'est pas si
simple que ça a analysé mais il est
majeur qu'on puisse en effet voir
quelles sont lorsqu'il y avait vous vous
aviez des protections s'il ya eu de
meilleurs de meilleurs résultats que
d'autres n'y avait pas de protection ça
c'est important
l'analyse est aussi est ce que vous
l'avez fait aussi n'a pas vous on n'a
pas fait évidemment à ce stade
pour autant la différence entre hors
pair en tout cas ce que moi je constaté
sur le terrain et d'autres adhérents
c'est évidemment une présence ou non en
grand test donc à une franche comté il y
aura toujours deux claques qui
s'affrontent en france jean claude
bologne parle de premiers cas autour du
20 mars
les premiers adhérents qui nous
appellent avec des cas extrêmement grave
on est autour du 6 mars à strasbourg
donc mulhouse strasbourg
la situation se dégrade tout au tout
début de mois et là pour le coup nous
n'avons pas de protocole effectivement
nous les fabriquons en temps réel et
pour strasbourg et mulhouse c'est trop
tard
ce dont bénéficiera paris qui
effectivement l'île de france c'est
plutôt au troisième semaine de mars que
les choses se dégradent
d'ailleurs il faut avoir l'humilité de
renoncer complètement planté on pensait
que le problème allait venir de l'italie
donc sur la côte sud est de la france
et en fait on n'a pas eu de cas en ce
qui nous concerne non pas eu de cas dans
un premier temps juste à la fin de
l'épidémie plusieurs cas asymptomatiques
mais vraiment pas de création disney la
région merci la deuxième partie de la
question s'adresse à monsieur champvert
et monsieur rizo voudra complété en ce
qui concerne la gestion des déchets
soient rapidement bellemare ddc pardon
rapidement madame la rapporteure
évidemment que si on avait eu des
masques des outils etc
ça aurait été beaucoup mieux on jouait
bien aujourd'hui des déteste aussi mais
je voudrais revenir sur les changes que
vous avez eue avec jean claude braud
dingue parce que je crois qu'il est au
coeur de ce que j'ai tenté de vous dire
tout à l'heure j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
d'empathie pour jean claude braud dengue
qui est devant la rapporteure d'une
commission d' enquête du sénat et qui on
sent bien que la rapporteure veut savoir
si tout a bien été fait ce qui a été
fait ou pas pour sauver des vies et
jean-claude bretagne dit on s'est placée
sous l'autorité médicale
eh bien ça nous ne l'avons pas fait en
france le président de la république
nommé un conseil scientifique mais il
n'a pas dit c'est le président du
conseil scientifique gouverne la france
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
vous avez continué à vous réunir à
débattre à soutenir le gouvernement à
vous opposer suivant vos orientations
mais la démocratie a continué en france
il faut bien voir qu'on est au coeur du
système et le dysfonctionnement du
système il est là nous l a dépeint on a
une vision différente pour parce qu'on
est meilleur que les autres
c'est juste que depuis les années 90 on
travaille sur une démarche qui s'appelle
citoyenne âge on écoute les personnes
âgées et en écoutant les personnes âgées
qui nous dit ce qui est important pour
nous c'est d'abord notre liberté
je suis une petite parenthèse on est
tous plus attachés à la liberté pour
nous et à la sécurité pour ceux qu'on
aime
ceux qui font du ski hors piste vous
explique combien c'est merveilleux de
liberté et souvent ils disent à leurs
conjoints et leurs enfants surtout
faites pas ça c'est trop dangereux
la liberté pour nous la sécurité pour
ceux qu'on aime
et donc ce qu'on a fait nous à l'ad-pa
dès le début et je pense que virginie
lasserre s'en souvient au tout début des
réunions de crise on a demandé la
saisine du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
je la remercie et je remercie le
ministre d'avoir accepté de saisir le
ccn parce que le ccnb lui il est dans
une autre logique beaucoup plus large et
je dirais dans une logique démocratique
et il dit bien sûr qu'il doit y avoir du
confinement
bien sûr qu'il doit y avoir des mesures
stricte yves de liberté nous avons tous
ce machin nous l'acceptons tout c'est
une décision du président et du premier
ministre on le fait on applique c'est
utile donc il faut bien sûr pour se
protéger un peu inquiété sur nos
libertés
mais nous dit le ccn les protections
doivent être individualisée
proportionnée et temporalités et dans
cette période du début
malheureusement nous n'avons pas
toujours été a dit visualiser
temporalité proportionnée c'était
compliqué moi je là encore je ne fait de
reproche à personne c'était compliqué on
était tous effaré mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui dans la période de
déconfinement est d'ailleurs le
ministère s'est appuyé sur cet avis le
protocole du rose août il parle
justement beaucoup plus d' équilibre
entre sécurité et liberté et d'
équilibre entre sécurité physique et
sécurité psychique et cette leçon je
pense qu'elle doit être au coeur des
débats sur la grande loi autonomie qu'on
attend et que que le président et le
premier ministre nous ont annoncé parce
que c'est un élément fondamental il ya
la question du manque de moyens je les
dis et puis vous l'avez entendu dix
mille fois vous le connaissez je
développe pas il ya aussi cette question
de citoyenneté
les personnes âgées ne dévalorise ont
pas ce qu'elles sont leurs aspirations à
la liberté même si elles ont des
troubles
même si elles ont des handicaps et
parfois certaines sont désorientés ça
reste des hommes et des femmes au sein
de la république
la question portait sur les décès je
vais je vais répondre à cette question à
ceux de deux sujets finalement remporté
j'avais cru comprendre de deux éléments
dans votre intervention le premier ces
impacts psychologiques sur les équipes
donc ça c'est un sujet que j'ai tout à
l'heure évoqué mais sur lequel je vais
revenir et puis sur la question des
deuils au moment où finalement de la
période la plus la plus difficile la
plus critique alors elle démarre
effectivement pour nous nous avons des
adhérents dans lesquelles les premiers
décès c'est le 4 mars
c'est le 4 mars et pas dans l'est de la
france
simplement parce que un établissement du
sud de la france a eu la malchance parce
que pour le coup il ya aussi une part de
malchance à ce moment-là précis au tout
dans les premiers jours de mars que
quelqu'un amène le virus dans
l'établissement et que ce virus frappent
les plus fragiles des résidents et avec
un enchaînement d'une quinzaine de décès
en quinze jours
cette période cette situation là elle a
fabriqué vous l'imaginez et vous le
savez des traumatismes lourds sur
l'ensemble des professionnels de
l'établissement de ces établissements et
qui continue qui vivent encore et qui
hélas sont difficiles aujourd'hui serait
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué le fait qu'
il ne faut pas attendre pour renforcer
aujourd'hui ces équipes là il faut
mettre en oeuvre d'ores et déjà des
moyens qui permettront à la fois de
soulager d'apaiser et parce qu'elle le
dit c'est très bien tout à l'heure mais
aussi de faire face à une éventualité
dans les semaines à venir
donc c'est un pacte écologique ils sont
aujourd'hui encore important est que au
fond la soudaineté la sidération du
début du mois de mars pour les
établissements très touché elle est
toujours d'actualité
et bien sûr parce que nous avons
beaucoup parlé en tout cas moi pour le
coup j'ai beaucoup parlé des
professionnels mais bien évidemment les
résidents et leurs familles il ya eu des
drames absolue on ne sait bien et parce
que parce que ça s'est construit un
moment où on ne pouvait plus ne veut pas
voir le corps de son de son parent parce
que voilà des protocoles et est ainsi
fait et je crois que cette réalité là et
selon apprendre de ces moments
particuliers il s'agit véritablement
tirer les conclusions et les
conséquences oui sans doute
sans doute qu'avec des équipements en
nombre suffisant on aurait prônant par
confiner je je je je suis assez
convaincu de ça et on le voit d'ailleurs
sur la société
on a aujourd'hui on a tous des masques
on a priori on est parent confiné chez
nous pas tout de suite et j'espère que
ce ne sera pas le cas mais en tous les
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que sur la jupe
sur le traitant particulier des décès
dans les établissements il y a eu
véritablement des drame absolu drames
humains qui ont hélas encore touché tout
le monde qui ont touché ensemble de
de la population et qui aujourd'hui on
le sait doit me permettre de tirer les
conclusions de ces réalités là oui
monsieur champvert lorsque je posais
cette question sur c'était justement
pour redonner à la personne âgée
vulnérable
il n'y a pas que les personnages qui
sont vulnérables mais et celles qui sont
dans les établissements leçon au premier
chef
justement toute leur place dans les
décisions et c'est ce à quoi lorsqu'on
sera notamment sur leur grand âge il
faudra veiller à tirer les conséquences
de cette crise une dernière question
j'ai oublié de poser c'est est ce que
vous avez dans vos les personnes qui
étaient malades dans vous avez évoqué le
renoncement aux soins du fait des noms
non programmation d'intervention ou de
tout ce qui était alors que vides de non
prise en charge est ce que vous avez une
notion de deux refus d'admettre à
l'hôpital des patients en fonction de
leur âge dans des personnes que vous
souhaitiez faire hospitaliser qui veut
répondre
rapidement on a interrogé pour préparer
cette réunion nous responsables à
l'ad-pa on nous remontent au fonds
directement comme ça abruptement peu de
situations de refus
je pense pourtant qu'il y en a eu qu'est
ce qui peut expliquer que y ait aussi
peu de responsables de l'ad-pa kiki qui
s'en plaignent probablement parce que la
profession est tellement habitué à des
difficultés d'hospitalisation même si
les choses se sont améliorées au cours
des dix dernières années mais on est
tellement habitué l'âgisme est tellement
fort je vous adresse quelqu'un il a quel
âge morts et puis ce qui me fait penser
que forcément il y en a eu c'est que
j'ai entendu sur une chaîne d'info en
continu un médecin urgentiste à côté de
ça il ya des médecins urgentistes comme
jules 20 qui ont dit qu'ils ont rappelé
les règles déontologiques y compris dans
l'immédiat c'est s'est jamais l'âge qui
doit être discriminatoire on doit
admettre ou pas hospitalisés ou pas en
fonction de l'espérance de vie
bon et ça julien a toujours été très
clair il a bien raison mais moi j'ai
entendu un médecin urgentiste expliqué
au moment où il y avait les débats en
lombardie
certains ont évoqué la lombardie
jean-claude vous voyez on pourrait être
confrontée à un drame disait ce médecin
on pourrait avoir à choisir entre deux
personnes de 40 ans sous-entendu ce
médecin s'ils avaient à choisir entre
une de 40 et une de 91 voyez bien que il
aurait pas eu de longs débats et bien là
il ya un vrai problème
et monsieur rizo oui on demande pas la
faire pareil dont nous n'avons pas eu
d'élément de remontée significative ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de services d'urgence et
d'hôpitaux qui ont été saturés donc ça
c'est une réalité évident corps et c'est
très tard les en demande la parole
monsieur mais verte oui alors titre
personnel donc sur l'alsace on a eu un
message le 13 mars au vendredi 13 mars
dont couler le service d'accueil des
urgences nous a signalé que comme il
arrivait à saturation
il y aurait certainement des idées des
choix à faire et là n'était pas question
d'âge mais était question de niveau de
dépendance donc ils ont parlé de gier un
gir 2 éventuellement 3 c'est le message
qu'on a eu
oui pareillement la première fois qu'on
nous signale ça me semble-t-il
effectivement on a rapidement madame la
déléguée on a des remontées mais
exclusivement en grand test et en
bourgogne franche comté en tout début de
crise des adhérentes qui nous rapporte
des refus très clair devenir en ehpad
pour transférer un rêve pour transfert
de résidents c'est localisé et c'est
pendant une courte période
effectivement l'état se rend compte du
problème et à partir du 20 mars les
filière gériatrique sont mises en place
dans tout les ars et en un temps record
cette fois ci mais puisqu'il ya des
lieux de soins vide puisque les hôpitaux
cesser les cliniques privées qui ont
cessé leur activité
on est mis en lien avec ces filière
gériatrique dans tout les ars il ya au
moins deux ou trois appels directs qui
nous permettent d'éviter le 15 comment
le demandaient depuis le 1er mars et on
l'obtient le 20 mars et à partir de ce
moment là il n'y a plus de problème de
transfert vous nous préciser très bien
par écrit parce que c'est important dans
la chronologie pour que nous rapporteur
puisse faire effectivement correctement
leur travail
merci je vais passer maintenant la râpe
parole pour leurs questions aux
commissaires qui le demandent
monsieur roger karoutchi s'est déjà à
toi
déjà c'est beaucoup dire mais bon
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mais mesdames
et messieurs moi je reste toujours sur
ma faim toutes ses auditions
bien sûr le rapporteur au miel a dit on
n'est pas là pour juger
on est là pour voir ce qui a
dysfonctionné pour établir
éventuellement les responsabilités
publiques dans les dysfonctionnements
mais on n'est pas là pour juger mais
alors pardon de vous dire quand je vous
entends j'entends bien qui a fait quoi à
quel moment le 3 mars au soir où le 5
mars au matin et ce qui n'est pas
rassurant c'est qu'au bout du bout
j'entends dire nous ne sommes pas prêts
s'il ya éventuellement une deuxième
vague
j'ai entendu monsieur mais vers dire
j'ai peur de ce qui peut se produire un
autre intervenant dire nous ne sommes
pas prêts et nos personnels ne sont pas
prêts alors moi je n'aurais qu'une
question et elle porte pas sur
l'historique pour savoir si tout le
monde a fait son job simplement vu ce
qu'il s'est passé je suis élu d'une
région où on l'a dit tout à l'heure
92% des ehpad ont été touchés par le
copil 92%
donc on a quand même comment dire
quelques inquiétudes
quels sont les trois mesures phares qui
ont été tirées de l'expérience et qui
font que si ça se reproduit nos ehpad
sont mieux protégés est-ce qu'il ya deux
trois mesures fortes qui quand même
change la donne
en ile de france comme ailleurs pour les
ehpad au secours
non oui merci monsieur le président donc
on a vu on a entendu ce matin avec les
les
l'aide à domicile et c'est que le coc
vide a exacerbé les manques des
politiques depuis des années concernant
les personnes âgées indépendantes etc
on voit que les ehpad notamment ont
besoin d'eux pour moi d'opérer une
certaine révolution dans la façon
d'accueillir les résidents et puis
d'avoir une vision globale
effectivement sur com comment notre
société finalement prend en compte les
personnes les personnes âgées
l'impression quand même qui qui qui
domine c'est effectivement on ne peut
pas reprocher un certain nombre de
d'approximations au départ quand on est
dans le vent la méconnaissance du virus
mais on est aussi à un certain moment et
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
quand catherine de roche demande une
chronologie
on a aussi on idée un peu perplexe par
moments sur un certain manque
d'anticipation des pouvoirs publics
on est très dubitatif par rapport à un
certain nombre un certain nombre de
données et le sentiment c'est que quand
même et je suis d'accord avec notre
collègue karoutchi il faut aujourd'hui
ensemble essayer de tirer les
enseignements pour ne pas reproduire des
choses qui n'ont pas marché ou qui ont
étaient nocives pour x y z raison moi je
suis très intéressé par vos réponses
concernant l' isolement dans les ehpad
parce que l' isolement a été une réponse
quand même dû en partie dus
essentiellement je dirai au manque
d'équipement masque sur blues etc
on a isolé les personnes on a vu que
l'aspect sanitaire et on n'a pas
les conséquences psychologiques
gravissimes et nous avons eu des
témoignages qui nous et puis on le sait
en tant que parlementaire dans nos
propres département des personnes se
sont laissé glisser et sont décédés et
aujourd'hui j'entends quand même à
nouveau parler éventuellement
d'isolement
donc moi personnellement j'aimerais
quand même connaître votre position là
dessus
il me semble que l' isolement n'est pas
la solution les personnes âgées
dépendantes ou pas d'ailleurs ont besoin
d'avoir un lion un lien social et ce
lien social
il passe par les professionnels mais ils
passent par leur famille par leurs
voisins par leurs amis donc ce n'est pas
la solution donc j'aimerai avoir vos
votre votre sentiment là-dessus deuxième
deuxième élément moi j'ai été interpelé
j'ai entendu ce matin toujours sur les
soins à domicile dire qu'il y aurait un
arrêt de l'approvisionnement en masque
un septembre donc j'aimerais savoir
madame lasserre qu'est ce qu'il en est
au niveau des ehpad
parce que si on demande à ce qu'il y ait
port obligatoire du masque pour toute
l'ailé de la population et on le voit là
au niveau du sénat s'il n'y a plus
d'approvisionnement des masques dans les
établissements alors effectivement là on
va isoler plus plus plus 3e troisième
question c'est que on parle beaucoup et
à juste titre c'est important de
protocoles de plates formes etc
mais en même temps je suis très
interrogatif sur le fait que tout ça
c'est très chronophage en matière de
temps passé par les personnels directeur
autres pour remplir toutes ses grilles
et pendant qu'on fait ça on s'occupe pas
de l'humain et comme il ya déjà un
manque de personnel criant et qui à mon
avis ne va pas s'arranger parce que
franchement vu ce qu'il vient d'être
vécue par les personnels
faut vraiment avoir la vocation ce biais
au corps pour dire on continue s'il n'ya
pas de changement n'est vraiment de
changement très fort en termes de
considération de la profession en termes
de modification des formations en termes
de salaires
donc on en est où là dessus est enfin là
est-ce qu'il faut pas justement au
niveau des protocoles des plateformes et
sert à faire un peu le ménage ne pas
multiplier les choses à voir une main ou
de dispositifs et puis que tout le monde
travaille sur ce même dispositif
et enfin la dernière question c'est que
est-ce que vous avez une évaluation ça
s'adresse là tout le monde du nombre de
personnels qui ont été contaminées dans
les établissements et aux également du
nombre de décès je vous remercie très
bien qu'ils commencent les réponses
aller mais je leur donne leur madame la
directrice
non peut-être pour répondre à la
première intervention du sénateur dont
monsieur karoutchi sur le les leçons de
la crise et est ce qu'on est
actuellement préparé à une dégradation
de l'épidémie je dirais que il y a des
acquis qui sont indéniables et qui nous
permettent de dire qu'on est en tout cas
beaucoup mieux préparer une reprise de
l'épidémie avec peut-être trois sujets
d'abord on a beaucoup dit un problème de
ressources humaines dans le secteur qui
est plutôt structurel puisque c'est le
secteur qui est peu attractif on a mis
en place des dispositifs de soutien en
ressources humaines à l'ensemble du
secteur qui sont maintenant sereinement
organisé avec une plateforme notamment
nationale qui s'appelle rang ferait rage
et qui désapprouve ans a enregistré
trois mille volontaires trait à
intervenir très rapidement dans les
ehpad si besoin est on a environ 1000
milles inscriptions de d'établissement
la plate forme je rappelle a été mise en
place fin juillet ses normes nationales
qui consolide les choses sachant que la
priorité c'est que les ars qui ont tout
monté pendant la crise des plateformes
rh elle-même puisse continuer à les
utiliser encore une fois pour pouvoir
apporter des renforts rh auprès du
service enfin du secteur médico-social
peut-être deuxième
axe majeur d'amélioration je pense avec
des choses dont on a tous rêvé pouvoir
les mettre en place depuis pas mal de
temps et j'en ai parlé dans mon
introduction
c'est la question aussi du de l'appui
sanitaire au médico social on a mis en
place des dispositifs pendant la crise
qu'on pérennise donc avec mes collègues
de la direction générale de l'offre de
soins
qu'il s'agisse des astreintes
gériatrique qui ont prouvé tout à fait
leur douleur tout leur intérêt
on a mis en place également des équipes
mobiles de soins palliatifs
on a mis en place et renforcer l'appui
des ces pièces qui sont les centres
d'appui pour la prévention des
infections liées aux soins et des
équipes d'hygiène hospitalière également
qu'ils interviennent encore plus sur le
secteur médico social
on a mis en place et cela est prolongée
au moins jusqu'au 30 septembre des
mesures financières permettant
l'intervention de deux médecins et
d'infirmiers libéraux au sein des ehpad
donc des systèmes de force et on est à
420 euros par exemple par demi-journée
pour des médecins pour permettre d'être
un peu plus attractif et pouvoir faire
en sorte que davantage de médecins
libéraux interviennent au sein des ehpad
et on a aussi l'achat des
l'hospitalisation à domicile qui a été
extrêmement développé pendant la crise
qui est aussi prolongé jusqu'au 30
octobre
et puis troisième chose qui nous permet
de dire que la situation n'est
absolument pas la même que celle que
nous connaissions au tout début de crise
est évidemment que nous disposons de
masques et de deux pays
les masques je le rappelle nous avons un
stock d'un milliard 52 million en stocks
stratégiques et à aujourd'hui donc je
dirais que
voilà on est quand même beaucoup mieux
armés évidemment pour affronter un un
rebond de l'épidémie alors si l'on
continue à répondre aux autres questions
comme vous le gouvernement de façon
synthétique voilà sur le showbiz sur le
confinement peut être dire
qu'effectivement nous avons pris la
toute toute les conclusions du comité
consultatif national d'éthique qui avait
rendu donc les conclusions le 30 mars
ont vraiment été je dirais complètement
prise en compte par l'état d'abord dans
un premier protocole le 20 avril on a
commencé à assouplir les mesures de
confinement c'était le protocole
contredit guedj mais surtout donc le
lors du protocole qui a été adressé à
l'ensemble du secteur médico social
le 15 août dernier nous avons redit de
façon très claire que les mesures de
confinement qui néanmoins de toute façon
dépendent de décision de directeurs
d'ehpad ne pouvait être prise que dans
des situations absolument exceptionnel
sur la vie de l'équipe médicale est en
lien très étroit avec les arts est donc
on est vraiment sur 7 sur 7 sur ses
consignes là mais encore une fois je le
dis ce n'est possible que parce qu'on
dispose dès à présent de masques et
d'équipements de protection
et puis vous avez parlé également madame
la sénatrice de l'arrêt de
l'approvisionnement en stock et un de
masques auprès du secteur médico-social
donc nous avons très tôt indiqué au
secteur qu'en effet l'approvisionnement
s'arrêter au 30 septembre et qu' il est
important que les établissements fassent
un stock de trois semaines en
utilisation en phase épidémique pour
pouvoir appréhender une dégradation
éventuellement de l'épidémie néanmoins
nous avons mis en place un suivi et un
dispositif de suivi très précis de
l'état des stocks et donc c'est en cours
de déploiement auprès de l'ensemble du
secteur du médico-social pour pouvoir
s'il ya un établissement était en grande
difficulté pouvoir réagir extrêmement
vite
et pouvoir de ce fait apporter des
solutions en masque auprès des
établissements dont qui en auraient
besoin
merci madame la déléguée générale juste
vous chercher les responsabilités vous
nous le dit depuis le départ geste il
est pas qu est ce qui n'est pas possible
pour nous de véritablement mais quand on
y réfléchit sans le mois de janvier je
pense qu'en france c'est toujours quand
même de la même manière que le sous le
même prisme d'un hospital au centrisme
public aiguë et cette crise l'a prouvé
c'est à dire qu'en janvier
tout est organisé du côté sanitaire on
ne peut pas dire que les gens ont dormi
au ministère de la santé ça a bossé dur
sur un guide qui sort de 100 pages qui
organise très parfaitement le doublement
voire le triplement des places de
réanimation en france ce qui est
complètement insensée quand on y pense
déjà en janvier c'est s'était pas
voilà donc le secteur effectivement
médico-social est arrivé après et ça on
le retrouve cette hospital au centrisme
aiguë on le retrouve bas de quatre mois
plus tard après la crise pendant le
ségur de la santé ont refait toujours la
même chose et on refera toujours la même
chose malheureusement puisque je pense
malheureusement mais en tout cas
l'hôpital lui a été organisée j'attire
l'attention sur les tests qui nous on
met fait tellement défaut tant défaut
qu'on n'osait même plus les demander
dans la première phase de la crise en
mars quand on veut tester
il faut demander des écouvillon à un des
138 centre covin en france on nous
envoie trois écouvillon avec le mode
d'emploi
on doit renvoyer les écouvillon au
centre qu'ovide qui nous renvoie les
résultats du jour plus tard donc en
début mars quand on veut tester on a
droit à trois tests par ehpad et une
fois que les trois tests sont positifs
c'est terminé fermez circulez ya plus
rien à voir on n'a plus le droit de test
donc ça plus effectivement les deux pays
un problème d'anticipation grave sur les
deux pays
évidemment aujourd'hui nous ne sommes
pas à trois semaines de stock ce serait
suicidaire que si les ehpad du synerpa
me disent qu'ils ont trois semaines de
stocks là je joue plus et on n'a
évidemment plus de trois semaines de
stocks parce que
l'unc on n'a pas envie d'être repris aux
mêmes au même jeu parce qu'en mars on a
trois semaines de stocks contre la crise
commence on est enfin de grippe on a
trois semaines de stocks
ce qui déclenche un problème grave c'est
la réquisition qui a lieu début mars au
moment où la réquisition arrive on ne
peut plus acheter des masques
c'est à dire que l'état achète les
masques que d'habitude nous avons nous
noté comme jean claude blanc que l'a dit
c'est un système totalement automatique
d'être livré en masse qu'on fait la
commande le lendemain elle masque au
moment où il ya la réquisition est bien
plus personne on appelle les
fournisseurs hindis terminé on peut plus
vous vendre et donc on se retrouve sur
des femmes stocks sans jamais savoir
quand est-ce que la distribution d'état
sera organisé
il faut attendre le courrier des
ferrades fédération que nous faisons
tous ensemble faisant état de 100 mille
morts si le ministre n'a fait rien à mon
ami le sel le poivre et c'est parce
qu'il fallait bien à ce moment là qu on
tire la sonnette d alarme eux
j'ai envie de dire heureusement ça fait
la tournée des médias alors qu'on ne
voulait pas trois jours après monsieur
verront annonce la distribution dans les
j'ai acheté des masques à partir du 20
mars
hélas depuis effectivement toutes les
semaines nous avons distribution de
masques de pays et la réquisition
s'arrête à ce moment là et nous pouvons
à nouveau
ré ré enclenché les commandes donc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que cette période
de trois semaines où on n'a ni test
nima ou très peu de masque on est obligé
de dire aux salariés non au nom de trier
les salariés vous vous êtes à côté d'un
résident vous avez un masque vous vous
n'êtes pas nos bad mask
donc oui à cette période là il ya eu il
ya un ton d'attentes qui est
véritablement préjudiciable qui
effectivement pose de grosses
difficultés
premier vingt martin à partir du la
réquisition a lieu le 3 mars par décret
et la première distribution de masques
aux automatique par l'état dans lé
groupement hospitalier de territoire a
lieu dans la semaine du 20 mars
sachant qu'on a tenté au départ les
pharmacies et que là ça va pas parce que
tout est pourquoi y'a réquisitions au
début on s'est dit mais l'état pourquoi
l'état fait une réquisition nous avons
besoin de ces mastre le problème c'est
que tous les français voulaient un
masque rappelez-vous début mars les gens
et en pharmacie demander des masses
s'énerver et on s'est dit si les gens
ont les masques dont on a besoin on est
foutu donc finalement cette réquisition
elle avait un sens même si elle nous a
voilà même si elle nous a posé problème
c'est pas le jour et la nuit bien
entendu on enchaîne bon monsieur mais
vers ton volant lors de la on a continué
le site a répondu l'homme monsieur
muller gg reprend les trois points aussi
le premier ce qui me paraît important
c'est des ressources humaines donc un
personnel en nombre plus important pour
pouvoir faire face donc à une deuxième
vague un nombre de personnels plus
importants efforts mais j'insiste aussi
sur la formation
ensuite aussi les eux pays mais pas que
aussi le matériel
on a eu des gros soucis pour l'oxygène
par exemple aussi les médicaments
puisque on s'est retrouvé comme très
vite en en pénurie de médicaments
essentiels en particulier quand il
s'agissait d'accompagner en fin de vie
et je pense qu'il est important que ce
soient pas concentrés sur le groupement
hospitalier territoriaux mais qu'il y
ait de vraies stocks dans les
établissements pour tous et pour tous
ces matériaux
aussi parce que on a eu quand même
l'impression que il ya une certaine
confiscation du matériel vers le
sanitaire aux dépens du médico-social
aussi donc ça c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste pour qu'on est à disposition
directement du matériel sur place dans
nos établissements
il y aura peut-être des problèmes
architecturaux il faudrait prévoir ça
aussi mais voilà c'est quelqu'un point
qui me paraît important
ensuite des tests bien sûr ça nous a
manqué mais là on en a le souci c'est
qu'il faut qu'ils soient ciblées c'est
un petit peu en ce moment du n'importe
quoi ça fait perdre du temps aussi pour
obtenir les résultats
ça fait donc augmenter le risque si au
lieu des 24 heures qui nous était
promise à ça mais trois quatre jours
comme on le voit parfois malheureusement
non pendant ce temps là c'est pas facile
de ma déjà d'isoler on n'a pas envie
désole quand testé négatif donc d'isoler
nos résidents et d'éviter qui sait
qu'ils entrent en contact avec avec
d'autres résidents qui leur transmettent
éventuellement le virus et des tests
donc prioriser aussi ça ça me paraît
essentielle
oui il faut que quelqu'un qui
qui travaillent en ehpad quelqu'un qui
résident népal soit prioritaire quand on
veut faire un test et qui passent avant
ceux qui se présentent dans les
laboratoires
qui font perdre du temps quoi tout
simplement trois mesure où une ou deux
mesures qui aient de meilleures
protections que vous avez c'était
surtout le sénat trois tableaux l'état
l'état pense que maintenant il peut
cibler selon l'état sanitaire ces
actions plutôt que de les faire de façon
unanime comme c'est de façon nationale
comme ça a été fait lors de la première
crise oui leader a fait d'avoir non
l'idée c'est évidemment dans une réponse
territoire réalisé en fonction de la
situation et puis débloqué une
amélioration quand même par rapport à ce
qu'on a connu et pour l'autre question à
qui avait été posée aussi donc une
remarque aussi les stocks
on constate tout ce qui est une envolée
des prix donc là on se retrouve quand
même avec un problème financier aussi
une économique aussi le problème de l'
isolement dans les régions comme comme
la mienne ou donc le virus a frappé fort
et vite
c'était d'abord une mesure d'urgence
je pense qu'on a fait et sauve qui peut
et je pense qu'on l'a bien fait même si
je suis pas un fanatique de l'isolément
il faut savoir que les allemands se
pratique aussi pour d'autres pathologies
en médecine habituelles voilà on isole
pas pour le coc vie dont nous on isole
pour bien pleins d'autres bateaux de
pathologies donc qui ont un risque de
compte
geo importante alors isolé quand quand
il ya des cas positifs dans
l'établissement il faut effectivement
que ce ne soit pas généraliser je pense
que ça c'était certainement une erreur
quand même que ce soit généralisé au
niveau national je pense que des régions
qui en avait pas besoin du tout et
surtout le jeu reprend les points aussi
pascal champvert donc la temporalité
donc il faut que ce soit arrivé lui
régulièrement et qu'on puisse dire bah
oui là il ya plus besoin c'est bon on
peut lever et ça on était peut-être
tellement dans la crainte qu'on a
peut-être un petit peu tiré sur la corde
aussi en gardant le confinement
peut-être au-delà de ce qui ce qui était
vraiment nécessaire
oh oui pour reprendre effectivement et
faire écho aux propos du sénateur oui je
crois que plus de matériel plus de
moyens humains
et puis et puis je crois qu'il est
extrêmement important ce qu'a dit madame
lasserre est tout à fait vrai c'est à
dire ces liens entre le sanitaire et le
médico social
là on en avait rêvé des choses
auparavant et la crise nous a permis de
le mettre en oeuvre ces outils-là de
fluidification de ces et c'est
extrêmement important c'est sans doute
là les trois aspects qu'on doit pouvoir
développer et conserver parce que c'est
pas naturel que le sanitaire et
médico-social travailler ensemble c'est
pas naturel que les établissements et
les services travaille ensemble et la
crise nous a permis de temps en temps de
le mettre en oeuvre il faut que ça
puisse se poursuivre sur la durée ces
réalités la sénatrice l'isolément il
était beaucoup évoqué oui évidemment je
crois qu'il faut user avec beaucoup de
modération et de prudence de ces de ces
outils-là de ce dispositif là je suis
assez convaincu que nos directeurs
directrices sur lesquels une grande
responsabilité a été a été confiée dès
le début de cette crise il a été dans
l'ensemble des des protocoles et des
communications dit que les directeurs et
est responsable de ce qu'il faisait il
le sont une honte et et je crois que là
encore ils seront usées et toujours avec
parcimonie de cette réalité là vous avez
évoqué la question de la simplification
ça me semble être un objet un objet
important et essentiel
il ya qu il ne faut pas là encore que
l'on sorte de cette crise avec autant de
complexité et de multiplication des
acteurs de ce secteur
je ferai juste je passerai sous silence
la question des coordinations diverses
et variées dont sans doute les services
de même si vous en parlait ce matin pour
pas pour évoquer un sujet la question
aujourd'hui de guigou qui pilote et qui
finance les ehpad est un sujet majeur le
double financement et le double
tarification a posé plein de problèmes
pas beaucoup évoqué mais on a beaucoup
parlé des récits on a peu parlé des
départements les départements ont été
parfois très présents parfois très
absent parfois très très très absent est
en tout cas toujours il ya eu sur le
territoire une ennemie une inégalité qui
a parfois était préjudiciable
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien quel point
il ya des degrés d'investissement des
départements qui sont multipliées par
autant que le département
ça a été vrai pour les ehpad ça a été
vrai pour les services à domicile pour
les autonomies s'imposer face à nombre
de problèmes et je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui dans la réforme du
dispositif si on veut simplifier il faut
aussi qu'on simplifie la question de la
gouvernance de ce secteur et qu'il faut
que dans la loi il ya des décisions
fortes qu'ils soient prises autour de la
question de qui fait quoi qui décide qui
financent et comment ça s'articule sur
le territoire à la finale et pas nous
sommes évidemment des grands fans de la
décentralisation puisque notre notre
réseau est constitué sur la base de
fédérations et d'associations locales et
régionales
mais il faut à tous les cas que cette
organisation-là assure non seulement une
simplification madame la sénatrice mais
aussi l'équité de traitement et une
logique territoriale structuré et
personne d'autre que la puissance
publique l'état et où la cns à nous
avons une idée sur le sujet doivent
piloter de manière forte
cette question de la gouvernance
territoriale ça ne peut pas être le seul
liberté d'un département quelle que soit
la volonté de ce département
merci monsieur changé
merci monsieur le président pour
répondre à monsieur karoutchi il faut
d'abord du retour d'expérience et
ensuite il faut du personnel du
personnel du personnel du personnel
juste une petite nuance madame lasserre
vous dit le secteur est pas attractif
c'est pour ça qu'on manque de personnel
moi je dirais c'est parce qu'on manque
de personnel que le secteur n'est pas
attractif parce qu'il faut du personnel
mais il faut du personnel comme l'a
suggéré madame cohen formés et valoriser
et pour rapidement eu une psy un petit
point quand même je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur un point très
important mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
quand le président de la république a
dit quoi qu'il en coûte pendant la crise
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui sa parole
n'est pas tenue il faut que deux minutes
un peu technique l'état beaucoup
d'établissements les les admissions
n'était plus possible pendant la crise
donc tous les établissements comme les
services à domicile d'ailleurs ont perdu
des rentrées d'argent puisqu'il n'y
avait plus de nouveaux résidents et que
malheureusement certains ont disparu
sauf que le quoi qu'il en coûte on nous
dit aujourd'hui ah oui vous serez
remboursé de vos pertes mais à hauteur
de 60 euros par jour je vous rappelle
particulièrement dans vos départements
monsieur karoutchi madame cohen qu'un
certain nombre d'établissements fort
heureusement son tarif et par leur
département à plus de 60 euros
tous ces établissements là vont perdre
la différence entre leur prix de
tarification et 60 euros
ça va aller de 15 jusqu'à 20 % pour
certains établissements faut qu'on parle
de ça parce qu'il s'agirait pas qu'à
cause de ça des directeurs
d'établissement soient dans l'avenir
amené à ne pas remplacer des
professionnels parce qu'il faudrait
payer le déficit de la crise or la seule
variable d'ajustement quasiment pour les
directeurs c'est le nombre de
professionnels donc il faut être très
très vigilant j'ai attiré l'attention de
la directrice de la cohésion sociale
sur ce point récemment elle m'a promis
de le remonter au cabinet et au ministre
mais je
vous propose la même chose très
rapidement pour répondre à madame cohen
oui
l' isolement a été excessif oui il était
dû au manque de masques oui on n'a pas
vu les conséquences psychologiques
l'isolément c'est une arme et toute arme
ça a des effets ça à des dommages
collatéraux et ils sont très graves vous
avez raison parfois
merci monsieur le président excusez-moi
si leurs traditions oui c'est juste une
précision j'avais aussi demandé si on
pouvait avoir les le nombre de
personnels qui avaient été contaminés et
voir qui était décédée suite à la
collision il faut remonter de façon
assez précise je vous propose de le
faire part par écrit un de façon à ce
que dans chacune de vos structures vous
remontiez il nous faut savoir quel est
le pourcentage de personnel touché c'est
très important me semble-t-il pour la
suite de notre enquête en place dans
chaque établissement qu'on est un peu
cette vision un peu différente aux
besoins peut faire un questionnaire plus
précis qu'on peut renvoyer peut-être
pour avoir les réponses que souhaitent
nos précise que souhaitent nos deux
rapporteurs merci je passe à la dernière
série de questions celle d'angel
préville arnaud bazin et bouddha angèle
préville merci monsieur le président
merci aux intervenants donc moi j'avais
je vais d'abord en première question
rajouter quelque chose de la question de
madame cohen
j'ai cru comprendre que certains des
patients qui avaient eu 7 7
ce que vivent 19 avait des séquelles et
y compris donc sur les bons il ya les
décès
mais aussi le personnel qui sort et qui
peut-être ne pourra plus travailler
comme avant
est-ce que s qui est ce que c'est il ya
une question sur ce sujet ou pas après
je revient également sur l' isolement
parce que je vais vous parler de mon
département qui a été un département
très peu touché et évidemment
l'isolément qui a été ok elle enfin qui
s'est donc appliqué à tous les
établissements concernant les personnes
âgées a fait que dans mon département et
particulièrement là où j'habite
les quatre établissements résidence
autonomie ehpad qui sont proches de moi
c'est à dire dans ma commune à 8 km et à
deux kilomètres
quatre établissements alors que mon
département le lot pratiquement aucun
cas donc par une personnes
asymptomatiques la moitié des résidants
ont quand même été testés positifs avec
des développements dans la 10 donc voilà
un isolement qui a été fait et qui a en
fait rendu captifs ses résidents et qui
a été dramatique donc là c'est un contre
exemple du fait que l' isolement voilà
je voulais quand même le signaler
parce que ça m'a beaucoup énormément
choqué et je voulais rappeler aussi
parce que on a parlé de date
je suis allé chercher tout à l'heure sur
internet la date du confinement à one
c'est le 23 janvier quand même donc le
23 janvier tout le monde sait c'est
largement relayée par les médias ce qui
se passe en chine
alors sauf à penser que peut-être en
france qu'on allait échapper à ça
franchement là on avait quand même et
puis on a vu ce que c'était le
confinement à one les gens étaient
livrés chez eux on a bien compris que
c'était très contagieux etc etc
donc voilà peut-être tiré des leçons de
de ce qu'on aurait pu faire et on avait
de ce côté là un petit peu d'avancé pour
anticiper les choses
donc voilà sur ce que je voulais dire au
sujet de l isolement et de peut-être
aussi concernant les résidents des ehpad
alors je ne sais pas s'ils sont toujours
en capacité
ed m
des voeux mais effectivement la vie des
familles et leurs voeux a eu quant à
comment ils sont traités
c'est vrai que là ça n'apparaît pas du
tout et que c'est quand même très
préjudiciable à ce que vous avez
évoquées tout alors voilà je remercie
merci michel meunier dit dans moi j'ai
une question plutôt à l'adresse de
messieurs ménard rizo et champvert
concernant le confinement en ehpad
c'est vrai que cette question ça
replacer la place de la fin de vie dans
notre société et ça a été rendue encore
plus cruellement visible un parent par
les médias pendant cette crise il se
trouve que la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat travail d'un
perspective de projet de loi grand âge
autonomie on a eu l'occasion de vous
recevoir messieurs rizo et ménard en
avril et déjà vous déploriez le
confinement des professions de personnel
libéraux exerçant en ehpad et donc
l'arrêt je pense aux orthoptistes aux
ergothérapeute orthophoniste au kiné etc
y compris aux coiffeurs et coiffeuses un
parfois puisque la prise en charge
encore une fois dans les airs et pas des
global est donc cet arrêt total a fait
parfois basculer les résidents on a
entendu parler du syndrome de glissement
beaucoup ce matin mais certains allaient
jusqu'à se laisser aller voir se laisser
mourir
donc voilà donc vous avez été à l'air
oui alerte nous avait alerté là dessus
vous avait alerté évidemment les
pouvoirs publics aujourd'hui en
septembre 2020 qu'est ce que vous avez
eu comme réponse on sait que les
déconfinement et les directives et
parfois même les contres directives du
genre jour à l'autre on fait que ces
personnels ont pu reprendre place dans
les ehpad et c'est tant mieux
mais qu'est ce que ça a révélé chez vous
enfin qu'est-ce que ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire davantage là où vous êtes
en tant que directeur de l'institution
parce que le modèle est fade et remis en
cause aujourd'hui on l'entend fortement
1 et on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans les semaines à venir évidemment et
madame la serbe pourrait peut-être
d'ailleurs mais c'est pas forcément le
cadre de notre audition
merci arnaud bazin merci monsieur le
président il m'a semblé comprendre tout
à l'heure de la part de délégué général
du synerpa qu' il serait observée
actuellement des symptômes différents de
ce qu'on a pu observer dans la première
partie de l'épidémie dont je voulais
qu'elle si je me trompe peut me le dira
mais si c'est bien ce que j'ai compris
qu'elle nous précise un peu les choses
et que quelqu'un puisse réagir là-dessus
ensuite sur les équipements de
protection individuelle il ya plusieurs
années le gouvernement a décidé de ne
plus tenir des stocks mais de les
décentraliser ce qui ne répond
d'ailleurs pas ont besoin du public
puisque ça répond besoins des
travailleurs dans les entreprises et
éventuellement des travailleurs dans les
établissements ou dans les hôpitaux mais
ça ne répond pas à l'ensemble du besoin
mais cependant je voulais demander aux
représentants des ehpad qu'elle comment
ils apprécient le niveau qu'on de
conscience de leur gouvernance de la
nécessité d'en d'avoir ses stocks et des
stocks d'ailleurs pour quelle durée
j'ai été très surpris quand j'ai
interrogé la déléguée de la rs lors du
point hebdomadaire que nous faisions par
audio conférence avec le préfet de
l'entendre me répondre que les gens qui
étaient résidents en ehpad ne relevait
pas d'une hospitalisation parce que
systématiquement le simple fait qu'ils
étaient en ehpad
entre guillemets dépendant permettait de
présupposés qu'il n'aurait aucun
bénéfice d'une ventilation assistée
j'ai été très très très surpris pour
tout dire même estomaqué presque
incapable de répondre parce que c'était
infligé ex cathedra et son débat
possible c'est parce que j'ai entendu
ici ou là non je voulais savoir si mon
département qui est un département d'île
de france qui a été lourdement touchés
fait exception ou s'il ya eu d'autres
cas semblables
et puis un dernier point pardonnez-moi
sur la question de l'isolément
je devrais savoir de quelle isolement on
parle parce que il me semble que quand
on interdit les visites des familles on
interdit les visites des familles quand
les personnels se confine avec le
résident c'est un isolement de
l'établissement qui est efficace
donc ma question est la suivante est ce
que les médecins estiment qu' à un
véritable plus à interdire les visites
des familles quand les personnels
continuent à entrer et sortir librement
dans l'établissement merci muriel jourda
merci monsieur le président j'ai une
question sur les protocoles
tout à l'heure il a été beaucoup évoqué
des protocoles la tente dans laquelle
l'établissement était notamment
l'établissement de protocoles par la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale
un premier protocole d'une centaine de
pages d'après ce que j'ai compris mais
qui n'est pas très praticable si je puis
dire pour les ehpad et puis plusieurs
autres protocoles vous avez indiqué
qu'ils avaient été établies mais
n'existe-t-il pas déjà dans les
établissements des protocoles en cas
d'épidémie type grippe comme monsieur le
directeur du rhdp a indiqué tout à
l'heure
et si ça n'est pas le cas n'était-il pas
possible que les établissements en
prenne l'initiative notamment
et là je m'adresse peut-être plus à
monsieur mais vas tu avec les médecins
coordonnateurs et aujourd'hui
existe-t-il des protocoles dans chaque
établissement d'accueil pour les
personnes âgées
deuxième question si vous permettez
monsieur le président qui rebondit un
peu sur celle de ma collègue michel
meunier
on a effectivement beaucoup évoqué le
syndrome de glissement ce matin cet
après midi c'est un syndrome qui est
n'est pas apparu lors de la crise du coc
vide
il a été identifié probablement parlé
par les médecins par les personnels
une alerte a été donnée disais tout à
l'heure michel m'a dit mais à qui cette
alerte at elle été donnée et comment at
elle été éventuellement ou pas prises en
compte sur les risques de glissements
liés à l'isolément des personnes âgées
c'est pour toutes ces questions on va
inverser l'ordre comme on a pris tout à
l'heure comme ça chacun va pouvoir
répondre en quelques minutes et de façon
précise monsieur changé merci monsieur
le président alors rapidement
madame meunier pardon madame préville
oui les conséquences pour les personnels
oui il faut réaliser value et c'est pas
fini on est encore là dedans et ça va
continuer comme on l'a dit à plusieurs
on est on est inquiet
madame meunier bien sûr qu'il faut que
les paramédicaux continua à venir et moi
je le redis bon il faut des renforts d'
équipe en urgence mais faut des psys il
n'y a pas de psy dans les services à
domicile quasiment aucun et il y en a
très peu dans les établissements quand
vous pensez pour un établissement de 110
personnes âgées il ya souvent un
psychologue mi temps mais si c'est une
honte quand on voit ce qu'on a enduré
des personnes âgées qui souvent des
femmes viennent de vivre quand elle
entend l'établissement à veuvage
les hommes aussi d'ailleurs mais ils
sont beaucoup moins nombreux quand on
veut certains ont perdu leurs enfants
quand on voit qu'il faut qu'ils
s'adaptent à des handicaps
supplémentaires moi je parle pas de
dépendance vous les comprimés de
handicap des fragilités des
vulnérabilités et ben quand on dit les
vieux s'adapte pas céder adaptation
colossal et on les laisse quasiment seul
par rapport à cela avec des
professionnels débordé il faut des
paramédicaux folie psychologue
monsieur bazin avoir des stocks ça pose
un problème c'est celui du financement
quand on nous dit c'est fini
l'alimentation stocks de masques à
partir de fin septembre je suis
extrêmement inquiet parce que les
établissements vont les payer alors au
détriment de quoi d'autre ou alors
est-ce qu'on aura les moyens
supplémentaires
et comme ça a été dit par jean pierre
riou à juste titre il ya des grandes
inquiétudes sur le prix d'un certain
nombre de pays qui explose
monsieur base à la directrice de la rs
départemental de votre département ben
oui c'est assez effarant c'est effarant
c'est effarant
moi j'ai entendu un médecin à la télé je
les dis qu'une directrice de rs 10 ha
ben non c'est à mes yeux il ya peut-être
un contexte un peut-être je dois être
plus nuancé
mais moi à mes yeux c'est c'est effarant
moi je partage votre analyse pourquoi
interdire les visites des familles alors
que les professionnels rentrent et
sortent enfin bon là la ministre dit il
faut suggérer le le comment le test aux
familles évidemment pas une famille qui
vient tous les jours mais mais une
famille qui vient assez régulièrement
oui c'est plutôt bien de lui dire qu'il
faut qu'elle se fasse tester pas plus
d'une fois par semaine c'est très
désagréable puis ça deviendrait fou mais
oui il faut se tester et pour madame
jourda les alertes ont été telles prises
en compte par rapport au syndrome de
glissement insuffisamment parce que ça a
été dit on a tous été dans une logique
de peur d'inquiétude
de deux c'est toujours dangereux de
donner parce que la société elle donne
quand même aux responsables
d'établissements jean pierre rizzo a
raison de le dire
ils ont eu beaucoup sur les épaules ils
ont beaucoup sur les épaules
on donne à des hommes et des femmes
quasiment implicitement la
responsabilité de la vie d'autres gens
bah quand on a la responsabilité de la
vie de gens en plus de gens très fragile
et très âgé et ben on a tendance à
surprotéger aide dans des logiques sur
sécuritaire c'est toujours la même
problématique
c'est pourquoi nous nous demandons que
les établissements alors dans la loi qui
vous sera proposé si vous êtes très
allants et ben vous vous transformez
tous les ehpad en établissement c'est à
dire en résidence autonomie et puis si
vous êtes moins allants vous proposez
vous acceptez a droit d'option pour tous
les ehpad kg vol et là on aura des
logiques démocratique beaucoup plus
puissantes et des logiques sécurité à
moi je dirige des établissements des
services à domicile
mais je vois bien à domicile si la
vieille dame elle décède on est tous
tristes mais on sera jamais accusé
d'être responsable
alors qu'en établissement on a toujours
cette épée de damoclès sur la tête basse
ça des directeurs qu'ils sont depuis
longtemps comme moi ça m'inquiète - mais
je ne vous dis pas que ça ne m'inquiète
pas et des jeunes directeurs et ben il
supporte pas et donc y conflit ni sur
protègent ils interdisent aux familles
de venir même encore maintenant alors
que c'est sans doute beaucoup trop et
moi je ne peux pas blâmer ces jeunes
directeurs ces jeunes directrice parce
que quelque part c'est la société qui
leur impose ça et ça c'est le modèle qui
qui dysfonctionnent donc à partir de
quand on a commencé à comprendre à le
prendre en compte
je cherche madame jourdain des yeux
pardon à partir du moment où comme je
les dis quand le gouvernement et la
direction de la cohésion sociale a
accepté de de consulter le comitat et
que le comité pendant consultatif
national d'éthique qui lui à la
préoccupation est évidemment de la
sécurité s'agit pas de dire on est pour
la liberté on s'occupe plus de sécurité
bien sûr qu'il fallait avoir la logique
sécurité en tête mais qui a aussi l'
équilibre entre sécurité et liberté
merci monsieur rizo 500 paraphraser
pascale sanvert et saint saëns en redire
sur tout ce qu'il a évoqué merci pascal
mal à madame la sénatrice préville oh
oui isolement a été sans doute la
généralisation en isolement et est
évidemment une mesure d'urgence qui
n'était pas adapté à chaque
établissement on le sait sur les 6000
ehpad de france toutes les situations
n'étaient pas les mêmes florence l'a
redit tout à l'heure et donc évidemment
qu'il faudra qu'il faut user de ses de
ces moyens-là avec parcimonie
c'est évident mal à manier oui vous avez
parfaitement raison on avait beaucoup
milité vous rappeler cet entretien nous
avions eues par visio à l'époque les
professionnels libéraux sont revenus est
effectivement au delà de la question des
numéros de kent libéraux et vous avez
raison de citer les coiffeurs les
coiffeuses parce que c'est aussi des
acteurs de la vie dans un établissement
parce que dans l'histoire c'est d'abord
un lieu de vie et nous y sommes très
attachés à ces réalités là ça veut dire
que concrètement il convient aujourd'hui
dans ce que la loi sera de réinventer un
nouvel établissement de le réinventer en
fonction d'une réalité qui est à dalle
on ouvert une
sécurisation allons nous vers une
syndicalisation de nos ehpad ou reste en
ouvert des ehpad qui sont d'abord des
lieux de vie ou dans lequel on reçoit
des soins et comment est ce qu'on
construit les pattes de demain dans des
logiques qui sont nés logique à la fois
très ouverte mais aussi des logiques qui
répondent aux attentes et aux besoins de
nos aînés d'aujourd'hui et de demain
ça me semble un point important le
sénateur en effet sur les stocks je
rejoins ce que dit pascal champvert a
lancé vrai pour les ehpad aujourd'hui
mais c'est encore plus vrai pour les
stades les enveloppes budgétaires
aujourd'hui sur les services de soins
infirmiers qui ont parfois jusqu'à 3000
salariés
ce sont des financements considérables
avoir trois semaines d'avancé que vous
avez 3000 salariés au prix coûte
aujourd'hui les masques dans un contexte
et je reviens ou les conseils
départementaux n'ont pas de ses nerfs
n'ont pas de ses nerfs de crédits non
renouvelables
on est là dans des problématiques
financières graves et ses problématiques
financières encore une fois bien sûr que
l'état ne peut pas se substituer tout le
temps à tous mais pour le coup c'est un
vrai enjeu autour des stocks et sur des
enveloppes de cet ordre là sur sur la
vie des familles on a beaucoup parlé je
reviens pas sur ce qu'a dit pascal
et puis je laisserais pascal pascal may
vaart parler de la partie purement
purement médical j'en suis bien bien
incapable enfin madame la sénatrice
journal oui des protocoles existait
auparavant
l'enjeu sans doute c'est que le pont
d'or que des protocoles qui sont nés de
cette crise due qu'aux villes deviennent
finalement une forme de repères en forme
de qui permettent d organisation au
quotidien sur les autres fléaux que
seront peut-être demain d'autres types
de deux des pandémies ou de canicule et
l'enjeu c'est d'intégrer en effet c'est
protocole à dans un fonctionnement qui
son fonctionnement un peu plus régulier
demain l'enjeu c'est que cette épidémie
se gère comme ne se gèrent la canicule
chaque année parce que aussi globalement
que chaque année on a des périodes de
canicule donc ces protocoles il existait
il vit sont venues se rajouter ceux ci
certains il y avait des plans bleu des
plans de lens existait déjà là
aujourd'hui on a des protocoles qui
viennent se rajouter et qui doivent
permettre de guider
les orientations des établissements et
le syndrome de glissement aussi je
laisserais pascal mais marta en parler
je suis bien bien incapable merci elle
hésite alors j'espère que je vais rien
oublié donc à propos des séquelles des
des personnels des soignants particulier
dans les ehpad
malheureusement pour l'instant on n'a
pas on n'a pas les chiffres je voudrais
juste soulignant qu'une chose c'est la
problématique de la reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle
quand même pour les pour pronom
personnel donc ce qu'on ce qui est sorti
pour l'instant je pense que c'est pat
pas vraiment satisfaisant c'est comme
très restrictif et je pense que les
personnels qui ont été malins dès qu'ils
ont des séquelles sont en attente de
quelque chose de plus avancée que cela
des enquêtes ont été faites auprès des
dans différents ehpad auprès des
familles des résidents aussi quand il
était en état d'y répondre par rapport
au vécu de l' isolement et moins les
retours que j'en ai eu c'est que il en
était plutôt satisfait ils n'ont plus
tôt vécu comme quelque chose qui les
acquis à préserver leur vie tout
simplement leurs fonctions vitales leur
vie
j'en veux pour preuve aussi que pour
l'instant à ma connaissance les
principales plaintes qui ont été
déposées contre des ehpad
c'est plutôt pour une absence de mesures
sécuritaires que pour une privation de
liberté d'aller et venir
donc je pense qu'on peut on peut faire
le parallèle entre les deux les visites
des familles pour moi ça reste quand
même un problème c'est plus dangereux
que la présence du des professionnels
les professionnels normalement sont
formés à l'hygiène
ils savent mettre un masque ce qui est
pas toujours le cas quand je croise les
familles des visiteurs donc dans les
ehpad je fais aussi un petit peu la
police parce que ça ne me satisfait pas
quand je vois comment voilà certains
portent le masque
comment certains le triture et il ya
aussi le problème du bas du des mesures
barrières qui sont plus respectées en
chambre ça c'est un peu normal voilà on
a envie de faire un câlin on a là on
enlève son masque ont donc pour moi il
ya quand même ce souci là donc je pense
qu'il faut être plus vigilant par
rapport au respect des mesures barrières
des visites donc dans les ehpad que les
professionnels c'est important pour le
professeur mais ça coûte plus de source
j'avais noté aussi pour que pour la vie
du conseil national donc d'éthique qu'il
avait été salvateur pour nombre d'entre
nous et je m'inclus là dedans je pense
qu'effectivement il nous a permis
d'ouvrir nos yeux
comme je disais tout à l'heure sur une
dérive qui était peut-être un petit peu
trop sécuritaire dans la durée et je
pense qu'il était bien venu cet avis là
même si au début ça nous a fait un petit
peu grincer des dents en disant mais oui
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec sa part le
parallèle qui est fait entre le domicile
et les ehpad
alors là je parle peut-être plus en tant
que médecin généraliste
j'ai franchement le sentiment que
on est face à des situations beaucoup
plus dramatique au domicile que dans les
ehpad
moi je trouve que souvent on sauve des
personnes âgées
quand ils sont dans un isolement
totalement insupportable dans un
dénuement parfois dans un oubli un
domicile et je fais parfois des pieds et
des mains pour arriver à faire entrer
ces patients là dans les ehpad
donc pour moi il faut il faut
effectivement garder cette solution des
ehpad
le souci c'est que les ehpad ont
complètement glissé aussi aussi un
syndrome de glissement des ehpad puisque
c'était d'abord des lieux de vie moi
quand j'ai commencé comme médecin
coordonnateur il ya pratiquement vingt
ans c'était
c'était d'abord un lieu de vie chili
avait à l'époque dénoncé jour où on
prenait en charge des cas plus lourds
donc où il y avait des soins plus plus
important est maintenant se retrouve
avec ses ses résidents là en ehpad
mais les moyens n'ont pas suivi ni les
moyens en personnel ni les moyens
financiers
donc le principal problème il est là je
pense que si on veut retrouver l'essence
des ehpad tels qu'ils sont censés l'être
il faut il faut réfléchir à cela
mais peut-être revenir quand même ou
long séjour je pense que ça c'est une
opinion peut être un peu plus un peu
plus personnel
voilà je sais pas si j'ai oublié quelque
chose je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
votre question par contre pas ce que
j'ai entendu que la fin
donc oui c'était alors moi j'en profite
pour rebondir dessus quand même on a été
très très embêté avec les protocoles
d'achat des d'hospitalisation à domicile
par leur look lourdeur et leurs
difficultés de 2000 ans de mise en route
surtout au début de ce début de
l'épidémie si on a perdu beaucoup de
temps à cause de ça donc bon il ya une
réflexion après qui s'est engagée mais
c'est c'est vrai que parfois des poudres
et des protocoles pour moi il devrait
être facilitateur et parfois ça peut
être à fera quand même merci oui oui
merci bien je vais en rond d'accord avec
avec florence j'ai peut-être donner un
éclairage un peu plus précis sur les
salariés c'est une question vous posiez
notamment sur les listings après qui
perdurerait l'approchent
les nouveaux cas qui se pose depuis
quand on observe çà et là différence
majeure que nous observons actuellement
et les stocks
après je laisserai la parole à florence
sur différents différents points alors
les salariés 25 mille salariés en france
nous en avons eu 997 qui ont été
impactés par le cos vie de plus du coup
on en cumul du 1er mars au 31 juillet
2020 dont 625 sur les 17 10 ans 625 sur
les ehpad 997 au total ce sont les
salariés du ssr je vous le rappelle qui
est aussi en t4 iméo nécessaire il était
en contact avec des patients posco vides
et des patients qu'aux vide puisque nous
avons pris système à l'envers lorsque
les hôpitaux étaient saturées nous avons
transféré les gens des maisons de
retraites sur les nécessaires une des
points
on peut poser c'est quand même
extrêmement important pascal que tu
opine de évidemment il fallait activer
les nécessaires on a pu le faire parce
que nous avons beaucoup dé ses serres
mais aussi grâce à elsa né à ramsey qui
sont d'autres groupes en france donc 997
salariés dont 625 en ehpad
aucun décès parmi ses salariés
heureusement nous avons encore le suivi
notamment de problématiques respiratoire
avec eux j'étais marqué mois par au
coeur de la crise je suis parti sur les
sites à la fois en europe
j'arrivais à voyager j'avais les papiers
pour et aussi en france et j'ai été
marqué par des salariés qui avaient été
soignants et non soignants d'ailleurs
qui ont été impactés par le cos vide qui
était mère de famille et qui ont laissé
les enfants parce que leurs maris
télétravail et qui au bout de quinze
jours revenait en disant ça va mieux je
suis protégé j'ai tout ce qu'il faut
j'y retourne pas ce qu'on peut pas
laisser l'établissement comme ça je
voulais le dire quand même parce que
s'ils m'entendre je voulais quand même
féliciter ces gens là parce qu'ils ont
probablement besoin encore énormément de
reconnaissance énormément de
reconnaissance
en ce qui concerne l' approche que nous
devons avoir avec les nouveaux car alors
déjà depuis le 15 août
mi-août à peu près on nous signale une
émergence de nouveaux cas qui sont dues
à plusieurs facteurs
oui je suis désolé il ya des gens qui
rentrent dans l'établissement comme vous
le disiez docteur qui sont pas toujours
bien protégés et ça c'est quelque chose
pour nous on a fait ce qu'on appelle un
retour d'expérience un vrai texte on a
15 ans quand on a demandé quelque chose
de simple on a 15 points qu'il faut
observer tout le temps que l'épidémie va
perdurer sur un territoire donné et ces
documents il à destination des
directeurs des équipes soignantes des
médecins coordonnateurs bien évidemment
les médecins coordonnateurs qui sont qui
sont commandés grand ordonnateur de ce
qu'on peut faire sur un rétablissement
donc on a utilisé sa et sur l'épidémie
aujourd'hui on constate à peu près 90
cas nous aujourd'hui sur 18500 pour
parler concrètement
90 cas depuis mi-août au total et dix
minutes tous les jours certains les
remplacent certains établissements les
remplacent 16 établissements 20 hier
voyez une diminution de noms
d'établissements peut-être que demain on
va augmenter mais en réalité on n'a pas
du tout le même type pour l'instant
d'épidémie que lors de la première vague
ce sont des personnes qui sont
majoritairement asymptomatique et nous
avons vu un décès qui selon les équipes
médicales ne serait pas lié directement
au co vide les gens sont asymptomatiques
est pour le moment
pour le moment le reste et nous avons eu
déjà des établissements depuis le mi
août donc nous sommes le 1er septembre
qui ont passé cette période clé des dix
jours que connaissent les médecins le je
parle sous votre contrôle docteur
modification des protocoles
évidemment il y en a trop des protocoles
il faut simplifier ça on a simplifié
ces points là et bien évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de formation
des équipes en ce qui concerne les
stocks qui avaient deux questions en
fait dans les stocks c'est là la durée
ou les maîtres et puis et puis si jamais
ça repart idéalement il faudrait qu'ils
soient ou pas ce que c'était un gros
problème quand même un pour avoir accès
à ces stocks là c'est une des questions
d'ailleurs que de votre questionnaire
secr ire de ma part les stocks nous
avons considéré qu'il fallait évidemment
deux mois réparti de la manière suivante
trois semaines dans un établissement
parce qu'on stoppe on ne stoppe pas que
des masques et ça peut peut-être vous
paraître stupide mais de façon
pragmatique sur le terrain ça prend
énormément de place les blues les
surblouse les surchaussures les gants
les lunettes les charlottes qu'elle soit
en papier ou en tissu les masques ffp2
tout ça prend énormément de place on n'a
pas forcément les locaux pour pouvoir
les stocker les surveiller et les
distribuer il faut les distribue
également aux salariés en lorsqu'on est
dans une zone à risque pour qu'ils
puissent rentrer chez eux
c'est extrêmement important c'est
quelque chose que nous avons appris de
cette crise ne pas laisser les salariés
qui notamment utilisé transports en
commun à partir avec des masques de la
journée il faut partir avec du matériel
propre donc oui ça consommé dans le
monde masque
laquelle et voilà pour cette audition
sur la situation dans les ehpad pendant
l'épidémie de coronavirus prochain
rendez vous demain à 11 heures avec une
nouvelle audition de la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur la gestion de la
crise du coroner virus très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
[Musique]